Where the fuck did my chat go?
Hello everybody!
Sorry, I just looked I was like, where's chat?
Why is it just a white space?
All right, don't worry It's it'll be alive.
Okay.
Wait, give me a sec.
We'll fix it.
We can always fix chat I can fix you.
You guys can't fix me, but at least I can fix you Oh my god All right.
Let's see Sorry, I just also like an hour ago just came back from the outside um so like i'm uh Why where's the game?
It's right here.
But like It's right here.
But like uh Uh, you guys always know in the beginning.
It's it's it's life update time Yeah Doki got nominated for the vtuber awards vote doki bird for vtuber of the year best fbs vtuber most dedicated fan base And best vtuber event.
Uh, thank you for the super chat potipo.
Thank you.
Thank you Yes, if you guys did not know the vtuber awards pinned in my chat has just been announced the nominees um, apparently I found out that um They put a limit on uh, there was a limit on like how many people how many nominations you can get as an individual and like,
uh, And like it's two so like my event nomination doesn't count as a as a person nomination Like I understand why I got vtuber of the year but like I was like man gamer of the year is feasible I Was like I was like looking at my competition in gamer of the year and vtuber of the year I was just like man It's there's a higher percentage To like potentially win in gamer of the year versus Versus vtuber of the year because I looked at who i'm up against in vtuber year and I was like from fighting the sack I'm almost going against the same people from the streamer awards,
and that's already really rough.
But like, no, I won't say I will win absolutely, but like, there's a higher chance for me to win for that one because like, I felt like I did a lot of gaming stuff.
I'm like, more gamer focused.
Yeah, so I was just like, it's scarier.
It's like, VTuber of the Year, it's a lot scarier because the competition is so much more fierce versus Gamer of the Year.
Yeah, I have a huge competition.
But thank you guys for nominating.
It makes sense because then there'd be like too many people would just like, like it makes sense to limit them.
Because like, I know like a lot of other VTubers, like the most nominations they got for individual wise is like two.
Because events and like fan bases don't count apparently under the same name, which is good because you guys got nominated.
We're still fighting the fight.
Yes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So like, it's more so like it's definitely a lot.
It's definitely the competition is a lot fierce versus some of the other categories.
But yeah, thank you guys again.
I hope you guys at least if I don't win anything, I hope you guys win something like.
I hope.
Also like, what the fuck?
Everybody else has actual FPS clips and then they gave me a fucking.
OK, so I also got nominated for FPS of the year.
And like literally everybody else has a real clip.
And then my clip is the one where I fucking step on a landmine and I explode.
Like, I didn't even get to use a gun.
You see a gun in my hand, but I didn't get a chance to fucking use it.
Like, what the fuck is that bullshit?
It's so rigged.
Actually, actually rigged.
Like, they'll click and they'll see my clip compared to everybody else's clip.
I thought I told you guys.
I thought I said if you're going to if I'm going to be in FPS of the year, we use the Mario Party clip.
What happened, guys?
I thought we were going to use the Mario Party clip.
I thought we all agreed.
I feel I feel sabotaged.
We haven't even got into the real thing yet.
I already feel like I saw it.
So I moved back a little bit.
The past Sturkey just died because I want to be more on the left side, I want to move more to the left.
Anyway, but yeah.
OK, anyway, another yeah, you know, that's just like, you know, how like in Rick and Morty, I know some of you guys might not watch Rick and Morty because like you won't understand.
It's where like people with higher intellect.
But it's like that Rick and Morty episode where you're not actually instant, but you're not teleporting.
Your past self dies while you create a new alternate self that goes forward.
So that past Sturkey that you just saw is dead.
I'm new Sturkey.
Anyway, as I was saying today, I went out because I tried to go to the doctor's today.
I tried.
I didn't get to go to the doctor's because if you guys don't know, if you're not Canadian and you don't know this, West Coast has an insane amount.
West Coast has a doctor shortage.
We have doctors.
They just refuse to practice, like practice medical stuff.
They refuse to practice their degree.
In our in our in West Coast.
So we have.
It doesn't matter how much money you pay.
We don't have enough doctors to look after people.
So yesterday I was like, I'm going to I'm going to get this checked out like I.
I'm going to get this checked out because like I want I it's been so long.
I have to record stuff, but I can't because I'm coughing a lot.
And like, you know, I'm going to talk a lot and stream.
So then I called.
Let me tell you guys, I called eight different doctors around several cities like near me.
I called eight different doctors and they all were like, sorry, we're not taking any new patients, by the way, we're not taking any new patients.
So then I was like, fuck.
And then I was ranting to this to one of my friends and then one of my friends apparently has a mutual friend that lives in my city.
So they're like, wait, maybe we can ask them and see we could use their family doctor.
So then like, um.
I was like, good idea.
So honestly, I the only way for me to see a doctor at this point is if I go to the if I go to America, like you know what's fucked?
One of my friends recently had to go to the doctor and then they're like, you should go to the doctor to get that checked out, because like they're like, I just booked an appointment like for tomorrow.
I'm just like, wow, I wish I had that fucking privilege.
They're like, yeah, I literally just called and just booked a doctor for tomorrow.
I'm just like, holy fuck.
Wow, you're so privileged.
Just do that.
Just be able to fucking call and get an appointment for the next day.
This was in America.
Like, like he like he's American.
And then I was like, like, wow.
So so so like, yeah.
Anyway, so, um, so my friend called their friend to see if I could mooch off their family doctor.
And then, and then the family doctor was like, sorry, we're not taking any new patients.
Maybe you could go to the hospital, but you have to wait six hours to get seen because, you know, it's free health care.
So I was just like, I don't want to fucking sit in a public hospital for six plus hours.
Like, I can't.
I can't.
And that's like, it could be six hours.
It could be longer.
Like, it's like, I don't know how long it's going to be.
Like, it's going to be the rest of my day.
Anyway.
So, um.
Anyway, so I was like, so today I was like, I have a plan.
I'm going to like, I'm going to go.
There's a like, there's technically a quote unquote emergency clinic, but that also does non-emergency stuff.
It's not the hospital, but it's like a clinic for emergency and also not in primary care.
So.
So I was like, OK, if I do, maybe I'll just walk in because you can do walk in, but like, it depends on if they are seeing people.
So then I was like, OK, maybe.
So I went there at like early and then I literally it was like, you know.
Two or three hours after opening, after it's supposed to be open.
So I went in and I was like, oh, there's not a lot of people here.
I was just like, there's not a lot of people here.
There might be a chance.
And then, you know, I was like, I'm here.
And they're like, what are you here for?
And I was like, oh, you know, I've been coughing for two months and it's getting worse, sort of.
And not really worse, but it's just not recovering.
And then she was like, sorry, we're not seeing any new walk-ins now.
We're like full.
And I was like, oh my god.
We could do a virtual assessment.
Just give us your number and then the nurse will call you and then we'll try to figure it out via the phone call.
And then at that point, I was like, within 24 hours.
And then at that point, I was like, you know what?
Like, I'm desperate.
Like, you might not be able to see what's wrong with me, but maybe I'll be able to describe it really, really well.
Like, I don't know.
I'm just like, oh, I'll just describe it really, really well.
So you'll know what's wrong with me.
So it's better than nothing at this point.
So within 24 hours, I'm expecting a phone call back about like a virtual assessment and then they'll see what's wrong with me.
There's no other thing, guys.
I can't.
I tried everything other than waiting at the hospital for six plus.
I haven't hit rock bottom yet.
Like, if this virtual assessment doesn't help me, I'll hit rock bottom.
Actually, no, it's either go to America and see a doctor or go to America and see a doctor or wait in the hospital for six plus hours.
It's that or the other.
I still have no idea which one yet.
I don't know which one to choose.
Anyway, anyway, so I was like, well, um, um, I was just like, well, since like, you know, there was like a mall nearby.
So I was just like, well, not nearby.
I was just like, well, since I'm out, I'm going to go to the mall.
I guess I was like, I'm just like, I'm outside.
I might as well head to the fucking mall.
So I just like decided to stay at the mall until I came back for stream because I was just like, you know, fuck this.
Fuck, I can't.
I was just like, I need some retail there.
Well, to be fair, I bought glasses.
Guys, I needed retail therapy, but like adult retail therapy.
And then I bought very expensive glasses because I was like, my old glasses is, um, is like really old now.
I bought this when I still like the glasses I'm wearing right now is a pair that I wore that I used to that I bought when I still lived in Hong Kong.
And then so like, that's old, old at that point.
That's incredibly old.
And so.
So I was like, OK, so I need a I need a I need new glasses frames.
So but the thing is, um, I, um, I've always wore this.
Yes, I lived in like different parts of Asia.
But like, I also used to live in Shenzhen before it.
I mean, it like it wasn't before then.
It was like barren.
But then like as I've lived in Shenzhen, it started getting more and more like advanced.
So like skyscrapers just started cropping up later on in the years.
So it's really surreal to see.
When I used to live in Shenzhen, it was literally like barren land.
Like there's like almost nothing.
But it changed.
So now there's like factories everywhere and like you can't see the sky anymore because there's so many lights.
Anyway, so.
Anyways, as I was saying, so I was like, the thing is.
The thing is, I always wore Lindbergh glasses frames.
So like I don't know other frames.
So I don't know anything else.
And so I don't know like what other frames to buy.
So I was like, OK, I'm going to buy Lindbergh because it's like the glasses the glasses I'm most familiar with because I've never tried anything else before.
So I really like Lindbergh.
For those who don't know the Lindbergh brand, it's the one.
It's like one of the lightest glasses frames in the world.
So like they're made of material that's like incredibly light.
So you don't feel like the weight on your face.
So I was like, OK, so I really like those because like I don't like feeling like the weight on my face when when I'm wearing glasses.
So it feels like I'm not wearing glasses.
And oh my God, wait, is this my doctor?
Wait, wait, give me a second.
Guys, I got a call.
I'm going to make sure it's not the doctor, or it is the doctor.
OK, I'm scared.
I don't I don't know who called me.
I was like, they are like, I didn't hear the first part, but they're like, we're looking for a Buddha.
And I was like, yeah, that's me.
And they're like, oh, sorry, please disregard that.
I thought, I don't think it was my doctor.
Probably just spam.
It probably was.
They just wanted to know if the call is like a real person or not.
And then I don't know.
They marked me off as a spam or something.
Um, yeah.
So, yeah, they're just like, are you they're like, we're this.
And then are you?
OK, yeah, I'm going to get ready for some more spam calls.
Anyway.
Oh, my God.
They took advantage of me.
I was waiting for my nurse.
I was waiting for my doctor call.
Anyway, um, what was I on?
What was I talking about before?
Um, what was I talking about before, uh, before the call, uh, glasses?
Oh, yeah.
Anyway, so I bought two frames because like one is like emergency and the other one's like one is for emergency and the other like for emergency cases.
And I wanted a new style anyway.
But yeah, anyway, so they were very expensive.
I basically spent like because you need to buy lenses, too.
I didn't realize because this is the first time I bought glasses by myself without like any parental guidance.
So like, by the way, I was a very I don't know.
I told you guys a lot.
But I'm a very sheltered child.
Like I was very, very sheltered.
So they're explaining to me about like different lenses and prescriptions and everything.
And I was just like, um, because they're like, OK, so which one did you want?
Like which one like with your prescription?
What would you like?
We're getting this or that.
Do you want the UV protection?
Do you want blue light protection and stuff like that?
And like, do you want the lenses to be like one point seven something?
And then I was like.
Um, this is my first time doing this.
My mom used to help me with all of it before.
And then they heard that.
And then they're like, we can milk money off of her.
Because that's what they did.
They took so much money.
Yeah.
So they're like, you need this and that.
And I was like, I don't know.
I guess I do need it.
I don't know.
And I was confused.
So they gave me so much information.
So anyway, so I spent a thousand dollars.
They're like, so you need an eye appointment.
You need an eye checkup to to to figure out your.
They're like, do you want to get it via your current prescription or like new prescription?
It's better to like check your check your current prescription.
Do a new prescription.
Because like, you know, it could be outdated.
And I was like, you know what?
You're right.
Maybe I should get a checkup now.
And then they're like, yeah, that's one hundred and twenty dollars.
And I was like, oh, OK.
I was like, OK, I guess I guess I did need an eye checkup anyway, because I thought it was like the regular way.
Because like in the past, when I did like, you know, when my parents helped me decide
if I need a new prescription, all they do is just, you know, scan your, you know, like do the eye thing.
They look into you, they do the eye thing where you look into the machine.
And then like the thing gets like less blurry and blurry.
And then you have to do the lenses like one or two, one or two.
That's it.
But I think I went with the more expensive route because they did that and then like seven other things to me.
And I was like, wait a minute, did I pay for the full service instead of the what is my prescription?
Because I was like, wait, wait a minute, I thought I was doing two things, not seven other things regarding my eyes because they're like, OK, so after this, I had to look into this x-ray thing that scanned my eyes where it was like a graph of my eyes.
It was like a green light and then it flashes at you.
And then I have to look at this other thing that blew into my eye.
I was like, the fuck is all of this?
I was just like, I was like, I don't remember any of these in prescription.
So, um, yeah, so like, um, that's normal.
But like, it's like the full experience.
I usually when I get like new prescription, I get like the two things.
It's usually like it's the one where you look into the thing and then like the picture gets more and more sharp.
And then the other one is the is the lenses.
That's it.
Now I did seven other things.
So I was like, oh, my God, that's that's a lot.
I was like, oh, my God, I was not expecting so many tests.
Um, yeah, so, yeah.
Um, I haven't I never done those before, so I was just like, oh, my God is what experience.
Oh, she's such a girl boss.
It's such a baby at the same time.
Dragoons, we can fix Doki one glass plate at a time.
Why is she like this?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ddragon, thank you for the super chat.
It's a show for high IQ people.
Also, Doki gets freaking 1k scammed for getting so freaking glasses.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And then so like, you know, they're like, oh, yeah, I was like, oh, yeah, I want contact lenses, too, because like I like the one day disposable contacts for like emergency cases.
Because I was like, oh, I'm getting new prescriptions, I might as well get new new.
If I if my eyes got worse, I should get new prescriptions for these.
Right.
Like that makes sense.
And they're like, um, well, you got to come back for a contact fitting.
I don't know what the fuck a contact fitting was.
So I was like, cool.
OK.
Oh.
That was an extra seventy dollars.
I.
So I was just like, what the fuck is a contact fitting?
OK, cool.
That sounds free.
And she was like, OK, you got to pay seventy dollars.
And I was like, oh.
Oh, I just thought I was going to buy it, just buy the contacts, but I didn't even get the contacts.
They're like, all right, you got to come back for an appointment for a contact fitting.
And I'm like, did I get an appointment?
So that's seventy dollars.
Plus, I guess whatever the cost is for like that appointment.
So I was just like, oh, OK.
So I was like, OK, that was that was my day.
Yeah, so.
Um, so yeah, that I got new pairs of glasses, but I can't pick them up right away because, oh, yeah, I I didn't know if I they wanted me to get blue light lenses, but like I I I didn't know because it was expensive.
So I went a tier below, which was UV protection.
I don't know if I fucked up.
Because like that was like the one time that was the one time I was like, maybe not.
So I went down a tier and it was UV light.
So UV protection.
So I was like, you know what?
Baby steps.
I like how people were like, you still got scammed.
Blue lights from your phone and monitor.
I stream as a career.
Wait, what do you mean it's not worth it?
But I wait, I should have got blue light.
I don't even go outside.
UV is for outside.
What do you mean?
Oh, my gosh, you got blue light.
I should have got blue light.
I stream as a career.
I don't even, I don't even go outside for the sun to hit me.
OK, anyway, so.
I sort of, I bought UV light lenses instead.
Because I went a tier below, and a tier below was UV light.
I don't know.
It was a tier below blue light.
Anyway, so, yeah, so that's basically I bought.
I was debating if I should get ice cream on the way, home, but it's so cold right now.
So I got like bubble waffle instead because I was like, you know what?
I spent so much money.
Well, I need, I need a stress seat.
I need a stress seat.
Also, the custom.
Oh, my God.
The fucking Apex custom.
Every day I scream into the void.
After, if I like start typing, it's because I'm in the middle of working on the custom because I'm waiting for Tempo to respond back because we were working on the custom regarding the sponsor.
So like if I start typing, if I tab out and start typing, it's because we're in the middle of that shit.
Anyway, I'm also going to work on my schedule today.
I debated.
I had a hard time deciding what to play because it was either this.
It was like I was before I decided to play Piglet's Big Game.
It was Epic Disney.
Oh, Epic Mickey, too.
Or it was Epic Mickey one.
But I realized, wait, I'm Indie now.
And I was like and I saw about I saw like tweets about Piglet's Big Game.
I was like, wait a minute, I'm Indie.
How did I get Piglet's Big Game to work?
I can't say.
But I'm Indie now.
Anyway, so so I was like, so I was like, fuck it.
We're playing Piglet's Big Game.
And I haven't I actually played this game on launch.
Oh, shit.
Wait, this is the doctor's.
Wait, this one actually is the doctor.
I'll be right back.
I'm going to make my call.
And I fucking, I hate the worst.
Oh, my God.
OK, the nurse, the nurse, the fucking nurse was like, I'm sorry, you don't meet the criteria for urgent care.
So you got to got to find a walk in clinic and see if any of the doctors would take you.
And I was like, it's been three months.
So and then she was like, you just don't meet the criteria.
I was like, what do you mean?
Well, she was because I told her I was I went on the trip and I I went on the trip.
And they were like, oh, yeah, because you went on a trip.
It's most likely you caught another virus.
So because of that, it resets because they're like, usually it's like, you know, three weeks or more, then we would consider it urgent care.
But then I was like, yes, but I've been coughing for like almost two, two months now heading to the third month.
And she was like, yes, but because you went on the trip, you must have caught a new virus.
And that virus is what we're counting right now.
And because of that, it resets the timer.
So like it is a reset the timer, but like it's two weeks.
It's not three weeks because it's not three weeks because it doesn't count.
It's because you went to travel, so I caught a new virus, apparently.
They're like, most likely you caught a new virus.
So like, that's why your coughing like came back, like even worse.
Not worse, but like it got worse again.
And so I was like, but it's heading to the third month.
And she's like, no, you just don't meet the criteria for urgent care.
And then I was like.
I was like, OK, so like, what do I do then?
Like, what are my options?
She was like, well, you got it.
You can Google and see if there's any walk-in clinics around you.
And I was like, but she was like, but they're not walk-in.
We don't do walk-ins anymore here in our in West Coast.
So we don't do walk-ins anymore.
But so you still have to make an appointment.
And then I was like, but I called A-plus doctors and they're all full.
And she was like, yeah, I'm sorry, sweetie.
Like, I know, but you just don't meet the criteria for urgent care.
I can't believe you can reset the timer of being sick.
Like the same thing.
And she called me, sweetie.
She called me sweetie.
And then so I was just like, at least write me a prescription.
Like, you know, I would assume she would like write me a prescription to.
I don't know.
I just, I I really assume that she would write me a prescription.
At least she's like, no, you just gotta find a way to get an appointment at a walk-in clinic somehow.
So, all right.
So my options is I go to the hospital and wait like six plus hours or go to America and get a doctor immediately.
Like, I didn't think, guys, if I knew, if I, yes, they call it walk-in clinics, but we don't do walk-ins anymore.
We apparently in our, in West Coast, we don't do walk-in anymore.
But like, we still call it walk-in.
You have to make appointments.
If they'll take me, just like I called eight different clinics yesterday and they were all like, sorry, we don't take new patients.
And I'm like, what do you mean we don't take new patients?
I don't know what to do.
I have a shortage of doctors.
We literally have doctors that don't want to work here.
That's like, we're so fucked.
We don't have enough supply and demand is fucking us up.
It doesn't matter.
I might throw money, I can't even throw money at the problem.
That's the worst part, guys.
I can't, I can't even throw money at the problem.
I, like, like, like private doctors won't take me in.
Like, public doctors, I have to wait six plus hours.
What do I do?
Go to America to even see one?
Anyway, I thought it would be good news, honestly.
All right.
So, yeah.
So I shouldn't have said I went on a trip.
I don't know why the fuck I said I didn't really.
OK, now I know.
Apparently, you know, you know, like, guys, you know how it's a thing where you're not supposed to withhold information to your to your doctors slash nurses when, you know, I went with that mindset, guys.
I went with the mindset of like, don't withhold information for medical advice.
Apparently, you should hold information regarding some medical.
Apparently, during some of these circumstances, I should have withheld that specific information.
I thought, you know, I thought it'd be helpful, but instead I got fucked over because I don't qualify for urgent care because I reset my timer.
I reset it.
All right.
So that's my update.
That's my update.
Mori, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Easy, you ask chat and get medical advice from chat.
Can anyone in chat write me a prescription?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
I've never been so proud of our shitty health care system.
If you have money, you'll get fixed up at the least.
America, fuck yeah!
Thank you for the super chat.
Johnny, thank you.
Thank you.
Dory, thank you for the super chat.
Meanwhile, America, they'll take you in right away, but empty your bank account.
I can't believe Wokki's become a restaurant reservation.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're like, oh, do you have like, um...
Like, is there is it just a cough?
And I was like, well, it's been almost three months.
Like, it's clearly not just a cough anymore.
It's been almost three months.
She's like, no, but it's just a cough.
You don't have any other like symptoms that like, you know, consider.
It's considered like urgent care.
And I'm like, I'm fucking coughing is not a great time.
I don't understand.
It's not a great time to cough every day.
Like, um...
That one dead guy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, don't withhold life-saving info like symptoms or ailment history.
But otherwise, treat doctors like the cops.
No snitching on yourself.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
OK, but yeah, anyway, um, that's basically.
That's basically it.
I'm back on trying to find a doctor again, trying to call her out.
This has been almost one hour of fucking.
It's been like one hour of like life up to.
It's been a very hard time.
God, it's just been.
Life has been pretty rough.
Thank you.
Oh, Justin, thank you for the magenta soup.
I just joined by notice you were nominated for three VTuber awards.
Congrats, Doki.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
This is your first super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, anyway.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
To be honest, all I can ask is if your cough is productive, as in when you have mucus when you cough and you do, what color is it?
It's like yellow greenish, but it's not all the time.
It's like sometimes and it sometimes is just saliva.
Guys, are you guys actually trying to fucking WebMD me right now?
Guys, it's not useful unless you're going to write me a prescription.
It's only useful if I get a prescription.
All right, guys.
So Piglet's big dream.
Like, what am I going to do if I find out I have something really bad?
It's not like I can go to a doctor's to get something.
I'd rather I'd rather be ignorant until like a doctor tells me what it is.
Because like, what if you tell me it's like pneumonia?
What am I going to do?
A doctor won't even see me.
I'm just I'm just going to be more like mentally like freaking out.
I'm just going to be like, what am I going to do if I think I have pneumonia?
Um, all right.
Let's play Piglet's big dream.
For those who don't know what this game is about, this game was actually so fucking scary.
I never finished it because, um, um, I didn't even get to the ER level for those who ever play this game.
So when this game came out, everybody thought, you know, back then, Disney games went fucking hard.
You guys didn't know that.
Their Disney Interactive Disney video game studio actually went super hard in their games.
Like, it's it's crazy.
So, um, I remember when I bought this, when my dad bought this for me, I thought it was just, you know, a fun Disney game.
But no, it was actually like, really?
It has they drew like Silent Hill slash Resident Evil aesthetics onto this game.
So there's like fixed camera angles in some cases.
And, um, and I didn't get to finish this game.
If you look at the soundtracks, if you look up this game's soundtrack, there is some like fucked up music in there.
And like, I never finished it because I was so freaked out and I never even got to the scariest level, which was Eeyore's level.
So, um.
I assume it was Eeyore's level, the haunted mansion one.
I never got to the mansion level because like I was I was already too freaked out.
So I never finished this game as I was when I was a kid.
So we're going to see how it goes now.
We're going to see how how older me is going to go with this.
Wow.
I don't know if the controller works.
I plugged in my controller.
So I don't know.
Oh,
this Canada has fast shipping.
Oh, wait, not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, Canada Post is still on strike, too, by the way.
So we're messed right now.
People in Canada cannot receive any.
People in Canada are not receiving anything.
Is my controller?
Oh, I didn't.
OK, guys, give me a sec.
I won't say how I'm playing this game, but like I need I need to make sure it's the right controller.
OK, wait, can I not do?
Wait a minute.
OK.
What controller is this?
This is.
Wait, can I not do this controller?
Oh, do I need an actual?
Do I need like an actual controller controller?
Like, can I not use guys?
Can I use.
A controller that might be.
Plus two.
Me.
That's all I'll say.
Oh, yeah.
It's a PlayStation controller.
I won't say the number, but it's a PlayStation controller.
What do I connect it as?
This is my first time, by the way.
I'm playing a using a PlayStation controller.
OK, but like what does what do I categorize it as?
There's like a wheeled.
It's not a wheeled device.
That's for sure.
What the fuck is it?
What do I categorize that as?
It doesn't say it.
It just says a microphone mouse.
Wait, should I just be like, there's a train controller, too.
What the fuck?
OK, settings.
God damn it.
This is so new to me.
Yeah, it's it's plugged in.
Yeah, it's pretty plugged in.
I assume it is.
OK.
Sure is.
I'm playing a PlayStation game right now.
I'm playing a PlayStation game.
Oh, I got to restart it.
OK.
All right, guys, guys, I'm restarting my PlayStation real quick, guys.
I'm restarting it.
God, I love being indie.
Oh my God, what am I using?
What is it called?
I don't even remember what it's called.
What am I using?
OK, so the meter's only one.
All right.
Remind me later.
Controllers.
Wait, but it says like.
It doesn't give me that option.
It just gives me like.
Oh.
Yeah, I'm restarting my.
I'm restarting my PlayStation, guys.
I'm restarting it right now.
Don't worry.
Wait.
It has.
Wait a minute.
Are you trying to tell me it's on PC?
All right, what did I?
Wait, really?
OK, wait, give me a sec.
All right.
What?
It's on PC?
OK, I clearly.
Guys, I'm new at this.
I'm so new at this, guys.
I didn't know there's a PC.
I went like, OK, I shouldn't say that, but like I went with PlayStation 2.
I went with PlayStation 2.
Guys, I'm so new at this, guys.
I'm actually so new at this.
That it's on PC.
Oh, my God.
Wait, what was that?
Well, what's that website I used?
Legal one.
The legal one.
No, guys, what do you mean no research?
I just didn't know how to get work on my PlayStation controller.
Like my one of my PlayStation's controller.
One of my PlayStation controller.
No, I can't, I can't see it.
I'm literally looking at it, it says PlayStation 2.
Guys, are you lying?
Wait, does it really have?
Is it really on PC?
There's no way, is it really?
There's no way it's on PC.
Wait.
Where is it?
The PC one is a fucking new one.
Yes, I know.
OK, how to connect.
PlayStation controller.
Oh, my God.
OK, guys, we're back.
We're learning.
OK, give me a sec.
I'll give you guys trying to figure out.
Trying to figure out how to connect my PlayStation controller.
If I write it down, it's not bad.
If I write, OK, I'm watching a video.
I'm watching a YouTube video.
All right.
Game controller.
OK, it's on controller.
What the fuck is this?
That's not what I'm using.
Oh, this was four years ago.
This was this was four years ago.
Everything's changed four years ago.
What?
OK, OK.
For why connection simply connect.
Well, OK, we didn't and click on plug in settings.
What the fuck is plug in settings?
Enable.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, hey, wait, I found it.
Wait, there it is.
OK.
Oh, there it is.
Enable DualShock 4.
Guys, I saw I mean, PlayStation DualShock 2.
Enabled DualShock 2.
OK, we figured it out.
OK, for 2.4.
Sorry, I like mixed it up.
DualShock 2, there we go.
We figured it out.
It gets easier, right?
With time, it should get easier, right?
With time.
Wait, how did I enable it?
It says I enabled it.
Does it actually enable?
All right, let's see.
OK, I'm going to make sure it's actually enabled like oh shit.
No, not like that.
Fuck.
OK, you're going to hear stuff because I'm making sure if it's actually enabled or not.
I need to make sure.
All right.
You're going to hear sounds because I'm double checking.
Wait, how is it not working?
I have my DualShock in there.
OK, a controller.
I enabled it.
OK, enable.
Let's see.
There it is.
It's in there.
OK.
It says it's connected.
All right.
You got it.
I got it calibrated.
I fucking got it.
OK, OK, I'm fucking calibrated.
It just says, OK, we're going to figure this out together.
It takes... Wait, how?
Oh, we're getting it.
Controller settings.
There's a controller settings.
Oh, is it?
Where the fuck?
Mapping settings.
No, that's not it.
How the fuck do I controller setting this?
Guys, just ignore the sounds you're hearing right now.
This is... Ignore it.
OK, oh, my God.
This is hell.
It's mapping.
Mapping settings.
It just says these settings ignore inversions as a result.
The... That's not it.
That's not it.
Guys.
I should have bought another PlayStation 2 that I legally own.
There's no... What do you mean there's no edit universal whatever you're saying?
Oh, my God.
I'm using one of the PlayStations on stream just started.
Hey, guys.
Rosie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, please, I went through so much already.
With the doctors, like, give me this at least.
Guys, please.
I went through so much.
Please, guys.
Oh, I figured it out.
Oh, my God.
I figured it out.
Wait, is this it?
Did I do it?
Oh, I did it.
Legally.
As legally as I can.
OK, let's go.
Let's go.
Alright, we gotta restart the game, though.
We gotta...
Because I skipped the intro.
We gotta restart the game.
OK, we figured it out, though.
We figured it out.
It's Piglet time.
Alright, it only took us an hour.
To be fair, I was only struggling for like...
I struggled for like...
Um...
For like 15 minutes at most, guys.
The most...
The rest of it was just spending on life updates.
And the doctors.
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you, Ophelia.
OK, that sure is high resolution.
I don't know what you're talking about.
That's how it looked.
That's how it looked when I was a kid.
And that's how it looks now.
That's how it looks now.
Don't stretch it?
Why?
What's wrong?
But it looks...
It looks better like this.
More balls.
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Look at that.
I told you my PlayStation controller works.
Alright, story time.
Yay!
Hey Piglet!
I'll sound out more.
Is it better?
Rabbit!
OK, the graphics for 20 years ago is actually really good.
This looks really, really good for 20 years ago.
I wish I could do a remaster of this.
Miria, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Toki, really glad to be able to enjoy my birthday even though you play such an interesting game.
What the fuck?
Anyway, thanks for this fun, making me smile.
Enjoy next year.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mira.
Yeah!
Yeah, the PTSD just kicked in there.
Christopher!
Silly Piglet.
You didn't take your meds.
Yeah Piglet, you're just crazy.
Silly old Piglet.
This is like...
Christopher Robin is just like...
Don't be a pussy.
That's not true.
They made an entire game for you, Piglet.
That line straight to Piglet's face.
Wow!
He ran away?!
Just cause...
Just cause they...
Oh my god, he ran away from home!
Because they're like...
Silly Piglet.
Stop being scared.
Stop being a pussy.
And then he ran away from home!
That's fucked.
Yeah.
You wanna create a new game?
Okay, I don't remember how the save file is gonna work, so I'm gonna...
Oh, okay.
Alright.
I wonder what I want my name to be.
Uh...
Wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Uh...
Wait, how many letters can I do, though?
No, no, no, wait, wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
Okay.
Wait, no, not L.
Fuck it.
Let's just...
I just wanna know how many letters!
That's what it's gonna be!
I don't know what the formatting does, so I'm just gonna do it.
Yay!
We saved!
It's too late.
I'm committed.
Mistakes remain.
Wow, just like how I remember my PlayStation 2 games.
That's how I remember my video games.
Wait, what's this?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's a vibration!
Oh my God, it is vibrating!
Okay, there's the credits.
What's this?
There's the center screen.
Okay, we don't need that.
Oh, this is like the volume, right?
Ooh, I don't know what to do here.
What's this?
How do I push this?
How do I get there?
Wait, I wanna get over here!
Select mono?
Oh, wait, that's smart.
Ball Buster 9000!
Oh, there it is.
Get over here.
How do I get you out?
Get out!
Oh, I guess he's trapped forever.
Do you like the music?
The two second loop of crazy?
Okay, I think that's good.
I think we're ready.
I think we're ready to go in.
Where's the soundtrack?
Welcome to a sneak peek of Piglet's Big Game.
It doesn't stop.
It doesn't get better.
It doesn't get better, guys.
This was me when I played this game.
Okay, and then, what's this?
Oh, Disney clips?
Oh my god, let's get in!
Oh my god, guys, you know what?
Let's legally watch Disney clips.
Yeah, I left my friends and now...
Oh yeah, this was where...
So, like, basically I have the power to enter their dreams.
Like, I don't know...
So, like...
What the fuck?
We're gonna enter Pooh's dreams.
Alright, let's bring it down overall.
Okay.
Alright, I brought it down overall.
Alright, time to go into your dreams, Pooh Bear!
It's time to incept you.
It's inception times.
That's what you get for calling me a fucking pussy.
I'm gonna go into their dreams and ruin their minds.
What the fuck?
And then Pooh died.
If you die in your sleep, you die in real life.
Okay, we don't need to save our game.
Oh, search for cookies!
Okay.
I'm gonna grab some cookies.
I don't remember what the cookies were for.
Guys, it's like, this game is 20 plus years old, guys.
Okay, I'm weak too.
Oh, cheer Piglet up!
Okay, but Christopher Robin's advice was so...
His advice was the reason why I fucking left!
Thank you, Christopher Robin.
I feel better already.
What's this, like, astrology advice I got?
I literally...
And oh god, oh, if we can bring down the...
Silence.
This game came out 20 years ago.
You think there's a music volume?
You think there's a music setting?
Setting?
Okay, so there's cotton candy.
Give me my cookies.
Yeah, 20 years.
That's...
Being able to lower the music was a privilege.
I low...
I turned it down.
Alright, I'll...
This is not scary.
Don't worry.
Yeah, it's a happy game!
Wait, what are you doing in this dream?
Oh.
He is?
Wait, but what are you doing in this dream?
I... I never moved.
I never moved!
What do you mean?
You nearly saw me here!
Alright.
What do we have?
Oh, look!
This is like Homer Simpson's dream.
And... I bet like, I think they like took inspiration from Big Piglet's Big Dream.
Or Piglet's Big Movie.
Okay, see, everything seems okay for now, right?
It seems like happy lands.
You're so strong, Piglet!
Oh my god!
You're so strong!
Look at you go!
Nobody can stop you in dreamland!
Oh, there's Pooh!
Hey, Pooh!
Eat yourself out!
Yeah!
But who's they?
Wait, Piglet, who's they?
Ask him who's they!
Okay, we gotta figure out how to get...
Well, we gotta figure out how to get him out.
Okay, so apparently...
Oh, rabbit?
Wait, there's rabbit in this dream?
There's rabbit in this dream?
In this dreamland?
The only thing I remember about the game...
Okay, so, I'm not gonna spoil you guys.
Oh, wait, I found a stick.
So, like, I remember the combat system.
The combat system is like really fucked.
Alright, grab onto my stick, Pooh.
Grab onto my stick, I'll pull you out.
Yeah, no, there's combat in this.
There's combat.
Piglet's gonna fucking brawl soon.
It's not what you think.
Combat.
Oh, what's Dream Rabbit like in Pooh's vision?
Oh my god, he's fucking built like a tank.
You hear the sound effects?
It's like...
Everything seems really... Yeah, guys, everything seems okay for now, right?
Like, look, everybody's happy and it's gumdrop land.
But, like...
You'll know why this game is fucked up.
This is just like how I remember my PS2 games in the resolution.
The high res HD.
I'm confused.
When does Sora and his keyblade show up?
Tori, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
lol
Yeah, the PS2 was really ahead of its time, guys.
It really was, though.
Oh, you might as well eat it.
Go eat it!
It's cotton candy!
Yeah!
Are you saying he can't do it?
Look at him!
Look at him.
He has so much space in there.
He can fucking fit that in.
How dare you not believe in him?
Eat it.
He's so hungry.
It's literally a dream.
Like, you can't...
Like, he can do anything in a dream.
I'm looking at this.
Ooh, help me with this.
How hungry.
Ooh, I need you to help me.
Okay, maybe I can tell him.
Hey, Doki, when I tried to stream a PS2 game, my monitor couldn't display the game.
It didn't show up on my stream.
Is there a compatibility issue?
Does anyone chat know?
Well, legally, there is no issue.
Maybe chat will know.
Yeah, tell us, Doki.
Okay.
Let's see.
How do I...
This is a game for children.
Ooh, just help me.
He's just watching me.
I think that's the most fucked up part.
He's literally just watching me jump.
Oh.
I don't even have a stick.
Okay, Owl, what do I do?
I'm desperate.
You're tall.
Owl?
Owl, you don't want to talk to me?
Owl, talk to me!
No!
Why does he want to talk to me?
Okay, maybe if I talk to Christopher for advice.
Maybe Christopher will talk to me, and then Owl will talk to me, because then he'll be like, Wow!
If Christopher Robin is willing to talk to Piglet, maybe she's cool enough.
I'm in.
Alright.
And then Owl would be like, maybe he is cool enough.
Owl, please.
Oh, maybe Owl will talk to me on the other screen.
Maybe the other...
Owl.
Owl number two!
There's another Owl over here, right?
Yeah, I remember.
There was another Owl here.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Okay, Owl number...
Oh, okay, never mind.
That was him.
That...
Owl, please!
I can't progress!
No!
I can't...
I just...
Owl, my soft lock!
He was Owl number two.
I don't understand!
Maybe if I get this one cookie he'll talk to me.
Maybe if I get this other cookie...
Okay.
Alright.
Owl, will you talk to me now?
Why won't you talk to me?!
Why?!
I don't...
Why won't you talk to me?!
Owl!
What did I do?!
Alright, maybe...
Oh, I don't know what to do.
You talk to me?!
I don't know!
He doesn't even talk to me!
I can't...
Owl, please!
I'm... Please!
Owl!
Please!
I cannot progress if you don't talk to me!
Owl, please!
Please!
I need you!
Okay, I'm gonna save my game and then see if that works.
Okay.
I'm gonna restart my game.
I cannot progress!
He doesn't want to speak to me!
Why?!
Why don't you want to speak to me, Owl?!
What did I do?!
What?!
Owl, please!
Guys, I need to restart my game.
I don't understand!
Owl!
What did I do wrong?!
What could I have paused?
Guys, I'm restarting my PS2.
Click.
Guys, I think there's a scratch on my disc.
Let me just...
Okay.
I put it back in.
There we go.
Now it should be better.
I blew on a disc.
I blew on a memory card too.
I blew on a memory card.
I got a towel and like wiped it too.
I got a towel.
I wet it and then wiped it up.
There we go.
That should be fine, right?
Dust got stuck on the disc reader.
It should be fine.
Maybe Owl will talk to me now.
Owl, please.
Please just talk to me.
I can't progress.
They won't let me do anything.
Okay.
My PS2 boots up fast?
Yeah, I got the...
I paid extra for the PS2 Pro.
Owl, please!
Owl!
I don't understand!
Guys, we can replay this specific section.
No, I got the PS2 Pro Slim.
You guys don't know.
Only like 10 were ever released, guys.
Okay, maybe there's like...
There's no way I got softlocked.
There's no fucking way.
Like, he's just staring at me like the fucking... He knows.
He knows.
He fucking...
He fucking knows.
How does he know?
How did you know?
I don't understand!
Please!
I really wanted to play this game.
Owl really said skill issue.
Thank you for the super chat, Cody.
Thank you.
He knows my secrets.
He knows what I did last summer.
Is this a horror?
Let me through, Owl, please!
Please, Owl!
Acknowledge me!
That's all I want!
I just want you to acknowledge me!
Owl, please!
I don't understand!
What did I do wrong?
Learn the other stuff I did, but what else could I have done wrong?
Okay, Pooh.
You might be on your own.
I'm gonna visit Rue's dream.
Pooh, he won't talk to me!
Let me through this cotton candy.
Perhaps Owl will know what to do.
He won't even talk to me!
I can't!
Oh my god.
Kick everything up.
I'm so mad!
I wish I could kick Owl.
I wish I could kick him.
I wish I could.
Please, will you talk?
You saw what I did.
You saw what I did!
Please, acknowledge me!
It's all I want!
He knows.
He's not afraid of me.
Alright, it's time to start a new save.
It's time to start.
It's okay, we're in the beginning.
Guys, we're in the beginning.
We can start a new save.
It's fine.
I don't need you.
I don't need you, Owl.
I never needed you.
I see this is why it's called a horror game.
This next save.
Okay.
This time.
This time it'll be different.
It's gonna be different now, guys.
It's gonna be different.
I figured it out.
I don't need his help.
This is it.
Alright.
Alright, this is fine.
It was the beginning, it's fine.
It's fine.
Okay.
Owl.
No.
His.
Alright, that's fine.
Now he'll notice me.
He'll notice me this time.
It will be okay.
He's gonna notice me this time.
Everything will be fine.
We're back in this.
Okay, I think all the volume stuff is fine.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Owl's gonna acknowledge me.
I can speedrun this.
I'm gonna go so fast.
Look at me go.
Owl, please.
Please.
This is the beginning, Owl.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We got this.
We figured it out.
Oh, I need a disabled widescreen on my PS2?
Okay, give me a sec.
I can do that.
Oh, but I like widescreen.
I like widescreen.
Okay.
Oh, man.
Now I have to do 4-3.
Okay.
I don't know if I should put it here.
Do I put it here?
Or put it in the center?
Guys, what do you think?
Return of 4-3.
Do I put it in the center or do I put it in the left side?
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm not a fan of 4-3.
Alright, here we go.
I like widescreen more.
Okay.
Fuck you.
Wait.
Oh my god, no, I couldn't speedrun this.
Alright.
Well, I could make it bigger.
You're right.
I just don't like 4-3 because of the empty space.
That's like my biggest issue with 4-3.
I hate the empty space of it.
There we go.
And then I'll put it behind me.
There.
Alright, let's go.
We're speedrunning.
We can do this.
PooBear, I'm coming over!
It's not like I've done this before.
Well, I have.
This is like...
Technically, I have.
PooBear, I'm coming over!
Oh, I need to talk to you before I get the stick.
This is it.
Alright, and then we get the stick.
Alright.
But hey guys, thank you for the super chat.
Alright, get over here, PooBear.
I figured it out.
Get over here!
Alright, everything is fine now.
Okay, now we gotta go back.
Oh, there's more cookies here?
Wait, I forgot.
I remember cookies was like a currency for something.
But I don't remember for what.
Wait, we gotta collect the cookies.
Like, I remember you have to use the cookies for something.
But I don't remember what it was for.
Oh my god, this is it.
Owl will finally notice me.
He'll finally notice me and acknowledge me as a person.
That I'm real in this world.
I knew.
I knew it.
That's the thing!
I thought like, since I'm a pig in an animal farm, they say that pigs are more equal than others.
Like, I should be more equal than an owl.
Why doesn't he acknowledge me?
Why does...
Okay.
We gotta grab this.
We read Animal Farm?
I went to school.
We all had to read Animal Farm.
Okay.
Alright, this is it.
Okay, Owl.
Get over here!
Talk to me!
He talked to me!
It's me!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
We did it.
No shit!
The water can't reach!
I don't...
I thought he was gonna give me a boost!
You mean this water?
That it can't reach?
You mean this one?
You mean...
That was the advice I...
Okay.
Let's get some cookies.
I had a rough day, guys.
And I'm not here for Owl's bullshit.
I'm playing at 4-3 for this.
He said we need water.
We didn't need to ask Owl for this!
We never needed to ask Owl for this!
There is an order to...
Absolute unit.
If Sora was here, he would figure it out.
Yeah!
Alright, we gotta find honey.
Wait, what?
What?
Heffalumps?
Not the he- Oh my god, he aged like 70 years from that?
Oh my...
Oh my god, when you hear that Heffalumps...
He actually...
Holy shit!
He turned like 80.
Okay, let's see.
Move the chat a little bit here.
Okay, so...
Did I scratch my butt and smell my...
Piglet!
I think Pooh Bear is a really bad friend.
Like...
Not gonna lie.
I think he's actually a really bad friend.
Wait...
There they are!
The Heffalumps and Woozles.
Okay, so there's gonna be a com- Oh look, that's me!
That's me!
Alright.
Let's see, we're gonna grab some cookies.
Real fast.
What is he gonna do?
Fucking kill me?
This is a children's game.
Okay, maybe I kick this.
Is there stuff here?
Okay.
I mean, it's a nice dream other than the Heffalumps and the Woozles.
Okay, we just gotta go here.
Oh.
Oh wait, this is where we came from.
Melting it...
Do I push something?
Oh wait, more cookies.
Okay, got more cookies though.
What?
I don't have any magnifying glass.
Yeah, why can't I just- I'm tiny, I can't just eat the door chat.
Not everything can be solved by eating.
How do I- Do I kick- Okay, at least I got this.
I think everything can be solved by kicking?
How do I eat the- Let's see.
Not with that attitude.
You didn't even try, Doki.
Where's the- No, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
How does he know?
Okay, we might as well kick this.
You know what?
Let's fight.
Wait, maybe it's the mirror.
Yeah.
Now I know why I got stuck on this game for a long time.
I'm not tall enough!
That's it.
That's- I'm gonna fight you.
I'm gonna fucking fight you.
Get over here.
That's right.
I'm gonna fight you.
Okay, I- Okay, nevermind.
I'm not gonna fight you.
Never-
Nevermind.
Oh no, I'm scared now.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh no.
No, I'm scared now.
Okay.
If we can't- There's no way.
Okay, we'll fight him again.
Okay, don't worry.
Now, get over here.
I'm ready to fight.
That's right.
Alright.
Get over here.
Yeah!
That's fucking right.
See?
There we go.
We did it.
We needed to fight him.
Yeah, that's the combat.
That was the combat.
See?
It's that easy.
I scared him so hard.
He turned into a potion.
Alright, now, where are- Oh, it's a birthday!
I'm playing a dragon D&D.
Anything- Absolutely can confirm.
Eating tourists solves all your issues.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, we got a candle.
Oh, we can- We can burn...
Burn the chocolate down.
Wait, there's music here.
That's right.
More cookies.
God, I'm too scared.
I walk so slow now.
Because I'm way too scared.
Wait, whose birthday was it?
Did I not get invited to a birthday party?
Alright.
Piglet's a weak- He's a weak, tiny pig.
He's not going to be able to eat the chocolate.
So he's going to burn the chocolate instead.
Alright, burn it down.
You know, this is actually like- I'm very surprised they added that.
Because I feel like a child will learn about this.
I feel like a child is going to try and do- Burn a door with a candle.
Turkey, please don't forget to collect the- Oracle gum.
So you can make piglets keep playing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Rabbit!
Dream Rabbit!
It's just one guy.
Fresh out in Winnie the Pooh's dream?
But it's quite dangerous, Piglet.
The bees won't let you near their honey.
Unless you find some way to get them away from their beehive.
How do we get them away?
Piglet, you need new friends.
You shouldn't have come back.
You shouldn't have- You shouldn't have come back after running away.
Alright.
I gotta get some advice from Christopher Robin.
Really?
Oh my god, really?
I can do anything if I believe in myself?
Oh my god.
What great advice.
Can you get the honey?
No, you just believe- Piglet, just believe in yourself.
And then you can grab the honey yourself.
Thanks, Christopher Robin.
True, that Zora looks weird.
Wait, what's behind me?
Wait, there was something behind me that could press.
Oh, there's the bees.
Wait, is that the- The woozles?
You can do anything.
What's this?
Oh, there's more.
Wait, those are upgrades.
I know, please upgrade my moves.
So I can scare them more.
I know.
Jesus Christ, that's actually freaking freakish.
It's like, let me break my jaw.
Let me unhinge my jaw real quick.
Real quick.
We got moves now.
We can unhinge our jaws like a snake.
Christopher Robin, the type of motherfucker who tells you to just stop being- That's what I thought!
That's what I was thinking too!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He's like, he goes up to you and just be like, why are you sad?
Just stop being sad.
That's literally him.
Alright, let's scare this woozle.
Get over here, woozle.
That's fucking right.
Yeah.
I don't have children reflexes now.
That's right.
Turn into a fucking potion.
You're not real.
This is why I don't take my-
Oh, believe him.
Oh, Darcy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, it's the raspberry!
He's real.
Get blasted.
Alright, this will make them want- They'll want berries over there.
Their queen.
Yes!
Leave your queen for berries!
Now I shall take all your honey.
And your children shall starve.
Not the bees.
Alright, let's go.
Rabbit could've done this.
Wait, I don't have a honeypot?
Wait, what?
They're not- Oh my god, I need to go back and get a honey- God fucking- Oh my- okay.
That's okay.
That's fine.
I can go back.
I can go back and grab a honeypot.
God damn, okay.
Maybe there's a honeypot here?
No.
Why didn't Rabbit tell me?
He could've told me before I went here!
Okay, Rabbit, I need a honeypot.
Languid.
Yeah.
We got the bees out.
I?
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait a minute.
Rabbit.
You're having a- Wait, was that Piglet's- Rabbit's birthday party?
Wait, that's sad.
Nobody came to your birthday?
That's so sad.
Wait,
what?
He's back?
I turned you into a fucking- I turned you into a potion!
Get over here!
Think I'm scared of you?
I'm not a child anymore!
I'm reflexes of an adult!
That's right!
Oh wait, it took more than one turn.
Alright, cry.
That's right, cry some more!
Turn into a potion!
Alright, I got a potion now.
Nice.
Wait, what do I do with the potions now?
Okay, I don't even know.
I don't know what to do with the potions.
That's right.
No, don't say that.
I wasn't born a pro- Don't say that, I was like- Wait, what?
Where is he?
Where even is he?
Okay.
Jesus Christ, when he unhinges his jaws.
That's so freaky.
The off-screen fight.
I was like, where did he come from?
Alright, got the key.
Unlock the door.
We could've used any other pot.
Alright.
Back to the pool bear.
Yay, auto-save!
Yay!
This is so sad.
This is actually so sad.
Rabbit was literally celebrating like...
her birthday by himself.
Also like...
Oh no, there's like Mother Rubear.
I wonder like...
Do they have jobs?
That's like...
I guess like...
Okay, to be fair, 100 Acre Woods is just Christopher Robin's delusions as a kid.
Like, those are like his...
Well, I wouldn't say delusions, because like he's a kid and he just has like a huge imagination.
But like...
Yeah, you know...
You know what I mean?
He's just...
He's just a very...
Very imaginative group...
Imaginative child.
He's just...
Yeah, it's like in his backyard.
Okay, there's...
I got it.
No, they're not real.
But then like...
Okay, this is the weird part.
Because like...
The weird part is that...
Yay, we got Honey!
Christopher Robin coma theory.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
To be fair, all the kids...
Like, all the fucking...
Theories regarding children cartoons is always about comas.
I feel like I don't need to fight them.
Like, I don't know what the potion actually does.
It's like when the VTubers click end stream button.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, here we go.
It's like every child children show, the theory is like...
He's in a coma.
The reason why Ash is still 10 is because he's in a coma.
The reason why X is like that is because they're in a coma.
It's always a coma theory.
I literally don't need to fight them.
I don't remember what was the use of fighting them.
Oh my god, there's two.
Wait, there's no way.
There's no way they still fight me.
Oh shit, cookies.
I remember the live action for Winnie the Pooh where they actually become real.
Yeah.
Character X is actually dead.
I did.
There's the honey.
You could've had cotton candy.
Here you go.
Yeah, Ed and Eddie were actually in a coma.
No, not the...
I can't believe...
I can't believe you guys forgot the Disney live action.
To be fair, it's a Disney live action to be fair.
They're all forgettable.
But there was a Disney live action Winnie the Pooh movie.
We don't talk about that.
We did it!
We're heroes!
Oh my god, we're so brave!
We found honey!
We're so brave!
We saved the world.
We got Winnie the Pooh honey.
Look at us go.
I thought it was good.
But some of you guys forgot about it.
I personally thought it.
I cried.
I cried at the end.
To be fair, it's forgettable.
I'll say it.
I thought it was good.
And I cried at the ending.
But I don't remember what happened in the movie.
Other than the fact that Christopher Robin becomes an adult and then the people...
Oh wait, what?
Where's my...
His biggest nightmare, he lost his ball.
But like, all I remember was that Christopher Robin stopped going to Hundred Acre Wood because he thought it was just all in his head.
And then Winnie the Pooh was like, psych, I'm here!
Yeah, where did he...
I just got into...
I just incepted.
It's Christopher Robin.
I didn't watch Blood and Honey.
Because that's what happens every time a property...
Oh my god, this is a child's dream.
He has no concept of furniture.
He has...
He has no...
What the...
Why is fire in PPS concept of fire?
You gotta be careful with rude Mrs. Kanga.
He knows what fire is, but apparently not furniture.
That's not good, Mrs. Kanga.
He knows what this means.
What does Christopher Robin has to say to me now?
Oh my god, that's all he tells me.
Do not tell me anything new.
Thank you.
Yeah, I know like Christopher Robin was a natural kid.
He still had plushies of like some of his old plushies in the museum.
Even the grasses, cardboard, the water, everything is cardboard except for fire!
What's wrong with this child?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh shit.
Even the water is not real!
Oh no.
Guys, I don't think Rue... I think Rue might be a pyromaniac.
Just maybe.
Okay.
That's right.
Reflexes of an adult.
Alright.
Let's get in.
Oh, there's something over here.
Is this real?
This isn't even real?
Is this cardboard a paint?
Okay.
Do the face.
Do the face, Piglet.
Get over here, Heffalump.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
I just need you guys to know, my reflexes were so slow back then that I have failed this combat and have died.
I've actually died.
I remember dying in some of the combat.
Yes.
Is anything...
Is there no... Is everything cardboard?
Is there anything that's not cardboard?
Are you cardboard?
Oh, there's a rock.
What if I paint the rock into a different color?
Oh,
okay.
So not that.
Okay.
No, he's just gonna be like, stop being sad.
I don't think that's you.
Oh!
Tigger!
The wonderful thing about Tigger is Tigger's a wonderful thing.
Break it!
It's paper!
Oh yeah, it's all about the Popeye horror film.
Lurkerosis.
Just jump!
You're literally...
Everything about you is jumping!
I don't think he's gonna take care of it, guys.
Wait, I'm playing...
I get to play the best character!
Alright, this is Tigger's big dream now.
No!
But I have to sneak!
Oh my god, he's not gonna know.
He's not gonna know.
How would he know?
I'll just run.
The fastest sneaking around.
Self-mission done.
Completed.
Wait, no, what do you mean?
I literally...
I did it!
How are they gonna catch me?
They don't know, see?
Look at that!
Turn around!
Oh, please!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
See?
It's so easy.
Wait, then where do I go?
Oh, I guess I go this way.
Ah!
No!
No, no, I'm scared!
No, Tigger, why are you scared?!
No!
You're a fucking coward!
God.
How did he know?
Was it my sound effects?
Yes!
MTS.
I don't understand!
Sorry, I was a little bitch, Piglet.
Yeah!
You should've been there, Piglet!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you should've been there!
Alright, Zero, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
My friend is playing this game with an Xbox controller but it's giving him GameCube quicktime events.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
Okay, we got this part down.
We got this part down very easily.
Alright.
He's not- That's what I'm saying.
I think Piglet has a really bad- I think Piglet just has really bad friends in general.
What does this do?
Oh!
I would've failed it anyway because I didn't do this.
I like how it's like a picture book.
Okay.
He won't know.
He's gonna turn around.
Oh my god, there's like music while I'm sneaking!
Oh, that's so cute!
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Can I make it across?
I think I can.
Boop, boop.
Okay.
Okay, there's no way they'll know, right?
From here?
There's no way.
No way, I'm like so far away.
No way, he's not gonna turn around.
It's just gonna be like...
Okay.
Yes, we did it.
We did it.
Okay, now we bounce.
Yeah, how would they know?
We're so selfie.
So easy.
Hahaha.
So safe.
You know what?
No, Tigger is like...
He's a bigger coward than Piglet somehow.
Look at that.
Piglet, you should've seen it.
There was like 500 Hufflepuffs and like 5,000 Wizzles.
Oh my god.
You should've been there, Piglet.
That's crazy.
Where did he go?
And he never came back down.
Wait.
He went back up and he was gone.
Alright, look at me.
Look at me!
That's fucking right.
Fight me!
Bro, he ascended.
That's fucking right.
Cry!
He's with his people now.
His people needs him.
We gotta go back here.
Now I shall kill all the Hufflepuffs.
It's okay.
Hufflepuffs don't have rights.
They're not real.
They're actually in your mind.
Oh, I have enough money.
NPCs hears comically loud spring noise behind them.
It must be wind.
Wait, I don't have money?
How much is it?
Piglet must buy all brave faces?
Okay, give me cookies now.
How much do I have?
I have 16!
Oh my god, okay.
We gotta save up.
I'm broke.
I didn't even realize I was broke.
Okay, we gotta farm some cookies.
The reason why we need more faces is that the attacks get stronger and the Hufflepuffs get stronger too.
I need so much money.
Guys,
it is a little concerning that the only real thing in this world was literally the fire.
It's very concerning for Rue.
Okay.
Get out.
Cry to your mama.
Pull the trigger, Piglet.
That's right, cry.
Oh, that's true.
The mom was real.
The mom and Tigger were real.
Those were the realest things in his entire dream.
And I guess the ball too.
So the important things in his life.
Okay, is there anything else I can kick?
Can I kick Rue's mailbox?
No, okay.
Rue!
Come out here, Rue!
Your mama, your dream mama is worried about you.
Just kick it.
Isn't this your house, Rue?
Get out of here.
I need a stronger move.
I definitely need 70 cookies.
Unhinge that jaw now, Piglet.
Oh yeah, they made a live action Popeye horror film.
How are you still alive?
Okay.
Eat the door.
Piglet can't eat chocolate.
Piglet, you think he can eat fucking paper?
Even Pooh wouldn't fucking eat the chocolate.
He wouldn't even eat cotton candy.
Alright, we gotta go back.
Well, I'll go back and grab...
go back to Mrs. Kanga's place.
That's true, pigs do eat anything.
Pigs don't care.
Except for Piglet.
He's a coward?
Okay.
Not this Piglet.
This Piglet's a fucking man.
What's this?
What did I grab?
What?
This entire place is cardboard.
What the fuck do you mean?
Like...
Dory, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rue moved out of his mom's house before I did.
What am I doing in my life?
Thank you for the super chat.
To be fair, I'm pretty sure rent here is like...
Okay, rent here compared to what rent we have to get?
Like...
Pretty sure in 100 acres wood, the rent is not as bad as like us.
Dory, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Funny enough, Tigger is said to have ADHD, but exhibits PTSD for... PTSD of what?
The Great Fucking Tigger War?
Yeah, just kicking stuff because I need cookies.
Give me cookies.
The Great Tigger War.
Oh shit, oh shit.
Okay, that was close.
I was literally right behind him.
I have the reflexes.
That's right.
My saliva.
Be afraid.
Be very afraid.
The Great War versus Tony the Tiger.
Alright, I think I can like run past these guys.
I don't... Okay, nevermind.
Nevermind, he was seeing red.
I got a little afraid.
That's right.
Be afraid.
It's not six...
Oh, I'm spitting at you and I'm not doing it within six feet.
I'm doing it within six feet.
Be very afraid.
There's more?
Oh no, that's not more Hufflelumps.
I thought there was more Hufflelumps.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, the red is an acorn.
That's so true.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Miss Kanga.
I did!
On the floor?
What?
Wait, I have a lot of cookies.
That's like mom talk for like don't come back.
Don't come back until mom has her mom time.
Oh, man.
I didn't even start looking for the key.
Mama Kanga still hasn't finished her wine yet.
Come back when this wine is empty.
Okay, that should be enough, right?
Mrs. Kanga?
Where's Mr. Kanga?
Yeah.
Wow!
There's so many cookies!
Why don't you go outside and find more cookies?
Oh, my god!
Yes, there's more cookies!
I've never heard about Mr. Kanga.
Oh, my god!
How many cookies?
Oh, there's more.
Yes, there's more.
Wait, you're right!
Wait, that's a lie!
That song was a lie!
Wait, no, he was the only one.
I don't remember.
Oh, no!
Oh, wait!
No, it's not a lie!
I remember now!
It's really sad.
He, like, thinks he has, like, a family, and he makes up in his own head about all the different family members he has.
So, like, in his own head, he thinks he has, like, a lot of different families.
Family members and stuff.
I never watched the movie, but I had, like, a picture book of, like, you know, like, the old golden illustration books as, like, for kids.
They don't do that anymore.
But I remember...
How?
How?!
I kicked everything!
There's...
What have I not kicked?!
But in, like, in the old times, they would have these, like, books, like, illustrated books and stuff that's, like, different, like, actual, like, illustrations, so they don't grab screenshots from the movies.
And, um, I used to have one...
Like, I had a collection of those and one of the store... Like, it was, like, those, like, giant books, and I had a collection of those because my parents would buy them for me to read.
And, like, one of them was, like, the that had an illustration of the Tigger movie.
So, like, he would, he would, like, brag about how he has, like, a million different family members and what each family member does, but then we found out that he's literally, like, alone.
He has no family.
Which is, like...
To be fair, he's not special.
Because Piglet has no family, but you don't see...
Okay, to be fair...
No, not just Eeyore...
We're talking about, like...
Who has it worse?
Jokey, this is not a competition.
But...
Who has it worse?
I'd say Eeyore has it the worst out of everybody.
Like...
Orphan, like...
The trauma dump face.
Yeah, at least Christopher Robin doesn't fucking pull out next to Tigger and was like, just stop being sad.
What?
What have I not kicked?
Miss Gengar!
I kicked this!
I kicked that!
What do you want from me?
I kicked everything!
And Eeyore is like...
Well, to be fair, Rabbit doesn't have his own movie too.
Is Rabbit Eeyore?
That's never had their... Oh my god, it's these two.
Like...
There we go.
Now we should have got everything.
I haven't found the key.
What?
I'm gonna kick you.
I'm gonna...
What else do you want me to kick?
I kicked everything!
I...
Oh my god.
Okay, Owl.
Owl and Eeyore have no movies.
Oh my god.
She's just like, stop bothering mom hours.
She's just like, stay outside for two more hours.
This is mom time.
This is true mom hours.
It's mom core right there.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm gonna kick everything.
I'm gonna...
Ugh!
I'm so mad!
I'm so fucking mad!
Alright, at least I can afford a face now.
Like, how much does she want me to collect?
Is it this?
Nothing works!
I can't even kick the rock!
Ugh!
I can't believe it.
They won't let me kick this.
They won't let me kick this!
She wants me to play outside for 20 more years!
Amateur, thank you for the very first super...
Your very first super chat!
Mr. Kanga died in the great Tigger war.
He was on the opposite side.
Have you ever noticed that Miss Kanga and Tigger don't like...
That Miss Kanga doesn't like Tigger?
And thinks he's a nuisance?
Now we know why.
I'm so mad.
I'm so fucking mad.
I'll never... Like, does she want me to collect every cookie?
Does she want me to collect everything?
It's like that, uh... that video of Mickey and Goofy, and then Goofy was like, Gosh, take the shot, Mickey!
Just take the shot!
That's what...
That's basically Tigger and Mr. Kanga.
Gosh, Mickey, do it!
Don't make me choose between you and my country, Goofy!
Uh-huh!
It's a great video.
That video lives rent-free in my head.
Honestly.
What?
You guys never heard of that?
You guys never heard of that video before?
It's so good.
Do it, Mickey!
Okay, wait, let me grab the link.
No, you guys can...
Actually, no, just YouTube.
Um...
Somebody just give them the title and then they can YouTube it.
Alright, at least we...
If I finally buy a face.
What face am I gonna get?
Oh, nice!
Shark!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Tigger came to 100 Acre Woods to make peace with Mr. Kanga.
Oh, no!
That's why he showed up later in the movie!
In the shows!
He was one of the later additions to, like, um...
To Winnie the Pooh!
Oh my God, it makes so much more sense.
It makes so much sense!
He was added later!
Because he came back from the war!
He came back from the war!
So they added him later.
It's canon.
It's always been canon.
Hey, Rude, do you know...
Did I get all your cookies?
And he plays with Rude, too!
He's like his new dad!
Because he, like...
He felt bad!
Because he took the shot!
That's why!
He felt so bad!
So, like, he's like his new father figure!
Because it was, like...
He's like, I promise Mr. Kinga that I will look after you when he's gone!
You're not my real kangaroo, dad!
You're not even a kangaroo!
But you can teach Rude to jump!
Because he's a Tigger!
So, like, you know how, like...
You know, like, dads who teach, like, their kids to ride a bike?
So, like, Tigger teaches Rude how to jump!
Because they both can jump!
So cute!
You made me happy!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Yeah, but...
Mrs. Kanga doesn't like Tigger, though.
She doesn't like him.
Now we know why.
She was like...
You're the reason why!
Who doesn't have a father?
It was all your fault!
And then...
Tigger was like...
I'm trying, Mrs. Kanga!
I can't do Tigger's voice.
Mrs. Kanga, I'm trying my best!
Alright, I did it!
Are there any more cookies?
What do you mean?
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Use the bathroom?
I don't...
I don't understand!
What needs to be kicked?
What is it?
What could it be, Mrs. Kanga?
What?
Did I not kick this?
It was the couch!
Did I not kick the couch?
I swear I kicked...
I swear I kicked the couch!
I kicked everything!
It was this!
I didn't kick that!
Alright.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got it!
There's no way!
I definitely kicked it!
Oh, you found the key.
Oh, you found it.
She just needed me to be like her fucking maid.
Oh my god, look.
Oh guys, how convenient.
She found the key.
So convenient.
She had it in her fucking Kanga pouch this entire time.
Wow.
She found it.
She decided to work just hard enough to be rewarded.
The piglet purgatory.
Red crow, thank you for the gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
God, I have so much kick energy now.
I need to kick something.
Wow, Doki.
She's trying to teach you responsibility.
How thoughtful of her.
Oh my god.
Sharky, thank you for the 5 gift chips.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just...
God damn it.
She's gonna crack one day.
Piglet's gonna crack one day.
He just hasn't hit puberty yet, you don't know that guys.
I like to...
Stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think like the freakiest thing about kangaroos is that they just poop out an embryo and then forces...
For those who don't know, kangaroo births they don't even...
They basically extract the baby when they're just a tiny little embryo with just tiny little legs.
It's like the size of a penny.
They crawl to your pouch.
They just start crawling to the pouch and just live there until they're fully grown.
Tokyo!
Yeah, and they live in that pouch.
They literally like...
Yes, I do.
Oh, there it is.
They like live there, they poop in there, they like pee in there, they eat in there.
They suckle on the teeth in that pouch until they're fully grown and then leave the pouch.
I was eating.
And they don't leave until they're fully grown.
You don't need real toys!
Did you see that?
His fucking toy is also made of paper.
That's so sad.
Thank you!
Yeah, so you don't want to get in that pouch, by the way.
The whole story about that is that you do not want to get in that pouch.
Oh my god, look at all these cookies!
God, I hate Mrs. Kenga.
I hate Mrs. Kenga.
It was not worth it.
Like how Christopher is like...
Christopher's advice is not... Oh wait, I can erase!
I can erase the rock!
I have power now.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can erase your entire world, Rue.
Don't make me angry.
I'm not grabbing all the cookies, guys.
It's not worth it.
Oh my god, look!
There's a picture of Rue holding his adopted father's hand.
Look at that.
My theory.
Oh my god, my theory.
It's not canon anymore.
It's becoming canon.
Oh my god.
I knew it.
I knew they're not delusions.
It's real.
Alright, we gotta go...
We gotta erase the rock and then find Eeyore because he's like behind.
I'm pretty sure he's like behind.
How do I leave this?
Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
See?
He has no other drawings other than his mom, himself, and Tigger.
So like my headcanon is becoming canon now.
Also, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, off we go.
I wonder if I'm faster if I do this.
Apparently, the speedrun tech is to get scared until you're super fast.
You know what?
I'm gonna do it.
There's no way I'll die.
Scare me.
I'm gonna do the speedrun tech.
I'm gonna go so fast.
Am I fast enough?
Come on, scare me again!
Scare me again!
I'm gonna get too scared and then I'm gonna die.
Oh my god, look how fast I am!
Oh my god, I'm so fast!
Also, the loading screen gets more depressing.
Oh my god.
Look how fast I am!
I'm speed!
Alright, there we go.
I don't like that the more scared I get, you can see like the black like I'm gonna fucking die or some shit.
Just running into the void.
Alright, let's see.
I got the eraser.
I can erase this world.
It's gonna make me angry bro.
I can erase everything you love.
Yeah, I don't like the shadows around the things we do for speed.
If I see Christopher Robin, I'll like tell him to make- to tell me not to be sad.
Guys, don't worry.
If I see Christopher Robin, I'll be like tell me that thing again.
Tell me not to be sad.
It's unfortunate.
His mom is one of the three things that has not made a paper.
Alright, we got this.
We gotta pull this.
Wait, what's this?
What's this do?
Oh, a hole.
What?
What is that?
You're right, I couldn't- no, the ladder is like also real for some reason.
What?
What am I building?
Okay, I need to kill- Okay, we'll get this one too.
I think I remember now!
Rabbit!
Rabbit was the- Oh wait, is this the boss fight?
Oh my god!
Wait.
Being an elephant.
Okay, do you think it was a- Well, it has to be.
Okay.
It has to be a male bee.
Okay, we gotta figure this out.
Oh my god, who do I fight?
Okay, but how did this come to be though?
Oh, easy.
Okay, we gotta get rid of this guy too.
I have the stronger move so he'll die faster.
I think like the further away, the stronger you can do the attacks.
I'm pretty sure.
The birds and the bees!
But instead of the birds and the bees, it's uh...
Elephants and the bees.
Honestly, I think it's more so of like
um...
The bee thought it was nectar.
And then maybe like the queen bee thought it was nectar and she was like... and then she just like landed on it.
And then it out came the elephant bee.
Because it grew from a larvae and then...
You had one?
Oh.
Oh, that's easy.
Yeah, you don't need a house.
Hey, Eeyore!
You can be homeless for a little longer, right?
Jesus Christ.
Eeyore, it's alright.
You can be homeless a little longer.
Look, this is Rue's dream.
He's clearly more important than you.
What?
Weirdoki, no!
That's literally what Piglin implied!
Piglin implied that!
He's like, can I use it instead?
That's so dumb.
That's more fucked up!
Oh, wait!
Oh, I can do it!
I got glue in!
If only he has this paper glue.
With this paper brush.
This gamerjokey's fun facts.
Night, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Dark, thank you for the super chat!
The size difference goes crazy.
I will give...
Oh, God!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my God, God!
He's homeless!
He lives in a sick house!
Look,
Eeyore, all I'm saying...
Eeyore, all I'm saying is that...
Rue's ball is more important than you.
But like, I'm not saying that, the game is saying...
I'm not saying that.
Alright, what's my attack now?
Jesus Christ.
Stretch your face.
Lurkrosis, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I could listen to Peter Cullen's voice Eeyore all day.
Oh guys, I finally watched Transformers 1.
It was on the plane.
I finally watched Transformers 1.
And...
Oh wait, what?
Wait, he's back?
Wait, the bees are back?
No, not the bees!
Not the bees!
It's okay, we're fine.
How far is he?
It's fine, I got the strong attack.
That's right, leave!
Leave, bees!
I'm gonna grab this, and then...
So I can leave this area.
Alright, nice.
I thought it was really funny that Chris Hemsworth voiced Orion Pax.
Or Optimus Prime.
It's so weird.
Because I was like, who the fuck is that guy?
I was like, who's voice is that?
His voice is so familiar.
Alright, Christopher.
Stop being sad, Piglet.
Piglet, stop being sad.
And then you'll be happy.
What do you mean spoilers?!
I'm just telling you who the voice actor is!
Wait, what do I have?
Okay, I'll just stay.
Look, see, I'm happy now.
It works.
It works, guys.
Dark Ace, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's be real.
Eyora was the gateway to Sad Girl for a lot of people.
Eyora and like...
Eyora and like Squidward were like for like...
edgy, sad kids.
Their quotes and stuff.
I remember I used to...
when I was young, I grew up in Catholic or Christian private school.
I don't know which one.
I always get confused.
And then like...
it was like uniforms and stuff.
No, it's true.
It was like, okay, we have uniforms.
But one day, we had a special day where if you give two dollars, you can wear whatever you want.
So like...
By the way, my parents bought me this shirt because my dad thought it was funny.
And like...
My dad...
Oh my god, there's so many Hufflepuffs.
I'm gonna run past all of them.
Oh god, okay, never mind.
That's way too close.
Get out.
Okay, so...
So like...
But it was like a special day where you pay two dollars and everything.
So it's not like...
It was like a special occasion.
So my dad bought me this shirt.
And the shirt read...
I can't believe I'm surrounded by stupid people.
And...
My mom let me go to school with that shirt on.
And I came to school...
I thought it was...
My parents and I thought it was hilarious.
Yeah, I got it.
It's right here.
Wait, it's this one.
And then, I went to school with that shirt on.
Teacher saw me in that shirt.
She pulled me aside from class.
I was like, you gotta change.
I did it!
Who the fuck are you?
Why is he green?
Wow.
Wow, Doki.
Where are you?
Fucking Glinda from Wizard of Oz.
By the way, I watched Wicked yesterday.
He's like, why is he fucking green?
He's the ball thief.
Give us back the ball!
We fucking sweeten the ears homeless because of this ball.
Freak!
He's a freak!
You want the ball.
How touching.
But you seem to be a little scared.
Oh, I've an idea.
If you scare me, I'll let you in.
But I think you are much too frightened.
Da-na-na-na-na was based off of Piglet's Big Game.
She saw...
The author saw...
What?
What the fuck?
Why is he groaning?
Like, why are you groaning?
I'm trying to tell a story.
Stop groaning.
It's making me uncomfortable.
As I say, Da-na-na-na-na was inspired by the guy that took his balls.
It all makes sense now.
I got so many scary faces.
Wait, I bought all the scary faces.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, I'll show you all my scary faces.
Watch this, door!
What the fuck?
That's a long combo.
That's right.
Now fucking... Oh my god.
I killed him.
That's right.
Rue, did you see that?
That was murder.
Wow, I just witnessed a murder.
Okay, so...
Where am I now?
I turned him to ash.
Poor killer.
What?
Rue, what the fuck are you thinking of?
What's going on in your head, Rue?
This is his mental health.
What the...
What the fuck is Rue thinking of right now?
That's okay.
Get out of my head.
No, it's not Piglet, it's Rue.
Oh wait, the dorm murderer.
Yeah, no, it's Piglet.
Piglet's the dorm murderer.
Rue's got a little bit of trauma going on.
Oh, thank god.
Turned into a potion.
A potion.
You know what he reminds me of?
Lorp.
I cannot keep up with internet memes anymore.
Like, I thought I was like, oh my god, finally.
I was like, oh my god, I'm catching up with the times.
And now there's like...
What's it called?
The fucking queen?
Queens don't cry?
Oh wait, he dodged it!
That's illegal!
You just closed your eyes?
You mean you can just close your eyes?
Okay.
Queens never...
I love like, I love like, my favorite part, my favorite meme of that part was like, um, devils never cry.
That one was my favorite part.
Like, meme of it.
Little me would have failed all of this, by the way.
Stop!
Stop closing your eyes!
That's illegal!
That's actually illegal.
This is like my entire job.
Oh no, no!
That's all I have!
The parry!
How is he parrying?!
Oh no.
Oh, he's getting closer.
He's getting closer!
The boss has hands!
There he has hands!
Alright, we got it.
Alright.
I got your ball.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm your new daddy.
Daddy.
What?!
He literally said like, you're braver than Tigger!
I'm gonna go up to Tigger and I'll be like, he calls me dad.
I'm counting his cabbages.
And Tigger painted everything orange.
Owl had fallen asleep.
Oh, it's time to accept Owl!
Oh, wait!
Guys, I'm gonna show you Eeyore's dream.
And you'll know what I mean.
Guys, I'm gonna show you Eeyore's dreams, guys.
I never made it to...
Wait, that means I never made past Owl!
Wait, I never made it past Owl!
Because I don't ever...
I don't remember doing Eeyore's...
Eeyore's level.
Okay, but I want to show you Eeyore's level.
Eeyore's level is actually pretty fucked up.
Out of all the levels.
Also, here, Optimus Prime's voice coming out of Eeyore.
What is Christopher Robin's name?
Where those faces Piglet was making.
That actually looks horrifically creepy.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is what Eeyore sees.
Piglet!
Hey, Piglet!
Oh, hello, Rue.
Do you know what's happening here?
I'm not sure, but this place is a little scary.
Everything's kinda dark.
Eeyore sure seems to be sad.
Even for Eeyore.
You're right!
Maybe that's why it's so dark.
Do you think you can cheer him up, Piglet?
You gotta be careful, though.
There are woozles all around.
I rest the streams.
I see that forest.
Alright.
Woah!
There's trees?
Yeah, I definitely never played this level.
It's alright.
Maybe he'll just stop being sad.
Just like what Christopher Robin said.
Stop being sad, Eeyore!
It works!
Jesus, this is what he sees.
This is what Eeyore sees when he wakes up.
Oh, hey, Amazon Prime.
Okay...
What do I move this, then?
What?
Do I move it here?
Oh, it's right here.
Wait, why do I move it there?
Oh, so I have to move something there.
What do I do with the pumpkin here?
Woah!
What?
Can I even kick trees?
Oh, I can!
Okay.
Okay, that gives me...
Okay, so that gives me cookies.
So I can kick these trunks for cookies.
What the fuck?
I don't have any...
Wait, back there, there was a lamp!
I didn't pick up a lamp.
There was a fire lamp behind me.
I remember.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, give me your lamp.
This is why you're a child.
Oh, there's a door here.
Let's talk to him.
Impression... Impression...
Good!
Woah!
Where the fuck?
No, balloon, it's just Christopher Robin.
Just telling me to stop being sad.
Like, it's...
It's sad.
It's just literally...
Stop being sad.
Why are you sad?
Is it not this?
Like, where am I supposed to push it?
What the fuck?
Is there anywhere here?
That I'm missing?
Can I get past these rocks?
I don't understand.
Oh, what the...
Oh, I can't go around?
Okay.
Wait, but...
There's nothing.
Oh, can I push this over?
Wait, what?
I don't understand.
Am I...
What the fuck am I supposed to do with this Goddamn pumpkin?
It won't leave!
It won't let me push... Can I push the pumpkin into the tent?
Maybe, let me try.
No, no, it won't let me put it in the center.
Okay, let me try this way.
Okay.
Yeah, I can either do left or right.
And I can't do, like, upward.
Like, upward down.
I fucking...
I hate this game.
I...
This is Amazon's fault.
This is...
What's that?
What the fuck?
Omega, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I've never played Honkai before.
So, I don't know, Omega.
What's in your bank account?
The bed!
Wait, is that the Joker?
Sellout, Joker.
You guys know I'm a sellout.
Again?
It's the green guy!
He's like the purple guy, but, like, green.
Oh my God, it's the green man.
Is that the green guy from 1987?
Okay, we gotta...
No!
Close his eyes again!
Fucking...
He did it at the last second!
Oh God.
Oh my God, he's so close.
He's actually so close.
Oh, thank God, he disappeared.
He fucking...
Shrunk.
Alright.
That's fine.
Okay.
Thank you!
She's having more trouble with these puzzles than...
Okay, like, I can't push it two sides to the right!
It has to be specifically two sides to the left!
Oh,
they're just normal enemies now.
Yeah.
What the fuck, Eeyore?
What have you been...
Are you having night...
Bro, this guy's been having night terrors or some shit.
Like, what?
What?
Where does this lead me?
You mean he's not homeless?
You mean he has a house all along?
I knew it.
I knew he was really depressed.
Yoki, that's so fun.
Let's see.
Okay, at least these guys...
This is his offshore bank account.
Okay.
That's right.
You can't close your eyes.
You don't have eyelids!
I know you don't have eyelids!
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Look at that perspective.
This is actually crazy.
This is my first time in this level.
I've only seen, like, one video of this.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
I'm freaking out.
Okay,
I need another face, though.
My faces are way too weak now.
They're too strong.
They have, like, x500 HP now.
Oh my god.
Yo, I was so scared.
Yo, legitimately, I couldn't finish this game.
I didn't even get to Eeyore's level.
Because I was so scared.
Like, look at...
Look at this!
Like, what the fuck?
This is so wild.
This is actually so wild.
It's so trippy.
I mean...
Yeah.
What happened with your interior designer?
I'll find all the colors of your dream for you.
That's very kind of you.
I don't think colors would fix this.
Piglet.
Yes, Eeyore?
Thanks for noticing me.
Oh!
Oh, Eeyore!
Did it work?
Did talking cure your depression?
Have you found the three colors of my dream, Piglet?
Three colors?
If it's too tough, you needn't bother.
Oh!
You're right.
Let's go back to...
Let's go to Al's dream.
You know what?
Maybe you're right, Eeyore.
Let's go to Al's dream.
Toki.
Toki, no.
It's fine.
Help him, Toki.
After everything he's been through.
Color red.
Oh, I guess it's like the primary colors.
And then you, like, mix it up.
Alright, let's get these guys out.
I don't see them.
Oh, they're so far.
Okay, I need to actually kick some cookies.
Yeah, they're so...
tanky now.
Oh, come on.
Oh!
Wait, they're so fast!
Don't touch!
Oh my god, he was so fast.
Did you see that?
He, like, literally shimmied over.
Oh god, oh.
Okay.
I need more distance.
They run now, yeah.
I think when they're closer to you, uh, they, like, start running.
But because they're, like, so tanky too, it takes me faster.
Oh, please don't!
Please don't touch me!
Nick, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, that's a puzzle.
The three colors of Eeyore's dreams are black, grey, and black again.
I see it.
Oh, I just gotta push this.
Okay, so this would go here.
And then...
Move!
What?!
What do you mean you don't move?
Okay, if I move it here, and then push it here...
Are you serious?!
Okay, apparently it was too close, so I can't move him earlier, but I can move him here now.
Okay, and then I'll move this guy here.
But how do I know if this one's the sword and this one's the shield?
I know this one has to be here, because it's the only way.
Come on, go in.
I know you're supposed to go in.
Go in!
Where else would you go in?
Go- move!
There we go.
Okay, we got one.
What the fuck?
That's a Resident Evil sound.
What the- What the fuck?
Are you okay?
But does this go here, though?
Okay, I need to make sure.
Okay, no, it goes all the way back here, because there's a sword there.
I saw it.
What the fuck?
That sound effect is from Resident Evil!
Okay, we gotta push this here.
Alright, get in there, sword.
Get in there!
Okay.
Please.
Maybe if I look around- turn around and rush back in.
Alright, nice.
Resident Piglet.
Mmm, I hate that.
I hate that sound effect.
I think it's like Onimushu, too.
Or Onimusha sound effects, too.
Get in.
Shield time.
I think it feels like- Okay, you played the other levels, this level literally is like so different compared to everything else.
Like...
I don't understand.
They gave this specific level to a different development team.
There's like no way.
Wait, where-
Wait, what?
Where did- Where did that door come from?
Where did that door even come from?
It's not from here.
Where did that open from?
I need to start kicking stuff.
I just realized- oh, there we go.
Sorry I kicked the painting of your great-great-grandfather.
But I need these cookies.
I am very short on cookies right now.
I really need a lot of cookies.
Okay, what other things can I kick?
Can I kick that?
Alright, I don't know where that door opened.
Where did that door open?
No, we're not gonna kick Eeyore.
He's been through a lot.
Guys, that's fucked.
Jesus Christ, what is this chair art?
Oh, it's in the yellow!
Okay.
Okay, that chair artwork is actually pretty creepy.
That's pretty creepy.
Alright.
Oh my god, I wish I could like pick stronger attacks.
Okay.
Oh no, he's running.
Rob, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It's the last hour of B-Day, so I'll spend it watching your stream!
What the fuck?
Who the fuck is he?
Who is he?
A new enemy!
Oh!
Wait!
Oh, wait, wait, wait a minute!
He can flip my screen?!
Oh my god, wait, okay.
Give me a sec.
Oh shit, okay.
It's fine, it's fine.
Wait, that's illegal!
Oh, okay.
Happy birthday, Rob!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday to you, Rob!
That's so fucking illegal.
Oh, I guess I have to...
Oh, I pushed that over here.
I think like...
He like...
If you do the move when he's holding...
Okay, the worst part about this is that you can't hold.
That's...
That's literally the worst part.
I have to like...
Just mash X.
How is this for children?
Exactly.
That's why I did not finish this game.
I made more progress in Kingdom Hearts than I did for this game.
That's how sad it was.
What did I unlock?
Sometimes it's like, what did I unlock?
Alright.
Um...
Because Kingdom Hearts wasn't that scary.
At best, the only thing that scared me a lot was... Oh, shit.
Was, um...
What's the first town called in Kingdom Hearts?
The one with the Final Fantasy characters?
I hated that town because like the Heartless would show up.
It's like, it wouldn't say it scared me, but like, I did not enjoy it.
Oh, this is the soundtrack.
I didn't enjoy it because there was no safe...
Yeah, Traverse Town.
I hated Traverse Town because...
Um...
I was always like spooked out about it because Heartless would like randomly show up.
I didn't like it because like there was no safe spot.
Yeah, it was like empty and eerie.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
Where am I?
And this is where the Rising Evil zombie shows up.
It goes, ooga booga booga.
Oh my God.
I can't see anything that's going on.
Oh my God!
Oh my God.
Heffalumps and losers?
Where?
Wait, where's the Heffalumps?
Where's the Heffalumps?
Oh, there he is.
Okay, it's just one guy.
It's just one guy.
It's fine.
Oh yeah, this was like Resident Evil.
This is like the dog.
It's the dogs!
Okay, that should be it.
Okay.
Oh, fuck!
How was I supposed to know there was more?
Okay.
Let's get him out of the way.
I really need a new face.
There's too tanky now.
Oh, oh, no, no, no.
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Okay.
That's right, shrink!
You're nobody!
Okay, maybe there's cookies?
Yay, cookies!
Cookies!
Okay, that has to give me cookies.
Yay, cookies!
Okay, I'll cook you.
That was literally yours money right there.
Yay, free cookies!
It's okay.
Eeyore doesn't need them.
He has a house now.
I mean, look at him!
He's clearly rich!
Look at where he lives!
He just doesn't have color!
What'd I do with the bottle opener, though?
Hell no, he won't notice.
He won't even notice they're gone, chat.
He won't even notice, guys.
He doesn't need these cookies!
He has like a million other problems to worry about!
Like, what is he gonna do with these cookies?
Like, first off, he doesn't have to worry about food.
Is there a big bottle in the other room?
There was a big bottle?
I didn't even notice it.
That's the last good thing.
He has so many cookies!
The first one?
This one?
I don't remember there being a bottle.
Is there a bottle?
I don't remember.
I'll go look.
I just...
Oh!
The giant bottle!
I thought you were talking about wine!
I was like, that's not wine!
There we go.
He's gonna have red at least.
Do I have to catch it, too?
Ah, fuck.
Okay, where is he gonna go?
Ah, this is fucked up.
Okay.
I caught it.
Yay!
We did it!
Wait, I'm here now.
We did it, Eeyore!
I found the first color!
We're gonna fix your depression!
It's that easy, Eeyore!
It's just that easy!
Eeyore, look!
One color at a time!
A color of blood!
Oh, you're right.
Just stop while I'm ahead, right?
I'll use the bathroom real quick, guys.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I still can't believe the nurse was like, it's not urgent enough.
You gotta fucking...
I'm still thinking about it.
I just got a cough job.
I'm like, I'm sorry, it's not urgent enough.
So you gotta fucking make an appointment at a walk-in clinic.
Because they don't do appointments.
They don't walk in.
You can't walk in.
They didn't even write me a fucking prescription!
Like, what is this?
What is this?
What the fuck is this?
Level design!
Okay.
We gotta fix this painting.
Wait, wait, wait.
What?
Everything is timed?
I'm so slow!
Yeah, that's what I'm saying!
That's literally Resident Evil 1 statue.
Oh my god, please, please, please.
I don't want to do well with pressure, please.
It's on the other side!
No!
Okay, that's fine, we did it.
That's the last one.
It has to be the last one.
Eeyore admires the human form.
Why is he dreaming about this?
Where's me?
And also, Eeyore, where's me?
Oh yeah!
All his best friends!
Pooh Bear, Owl, Tigger, Rabbit.
Where's me?
Bro, what the fuck, man?
I'm trying to make you less depressed.
Oh!
He's a child!
I don't think Eeyore wants to be friends with a kid.
That's fucked.
I see.
I see how it is, Eeyore.
I see how it is.
I fucking see how it is.
Why?
Oh!
If I turn everything off...
Maybe it'll like...
And then, there has to be one more over here.
Yeah, yeah, if I turn this off...
And then the fountain is gonna stop working.
Okay.
And it's gonna explode.
And now Eeyore's gonna have plumbing issues and he's gonna be homeless again.
Yay!
He didn't see me.
He's like, what?
Is it?
How do I...
Grab this then?
Wait, who's here?
Who's here?
Okay.
Get out of here.
Yay!
Eeyore's gonna have financial issues!
Oh shit.
Okay, now he's like really close.
I think I have to do one more too.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no!
No touch!
No!
You're so mean!
Wait, there's another one?
Oh my god.
Fuck, it's the green man!
Okay.
Just gotta make sure he...
He doesn't close his eyes.
Bro, why are we Luigi Manchu right now?
Just how twisted and messed up is this?
Is Eeyore's mental state...
Okay.
No, what did he say?
What did the narrator say?
I don't know...
I don't know if like...
If it resets their HP.
So if it resets their...
Oh, it doesn't, thank god.
Oh, thank god.
For real though, what in the core of that is this?
Is Eeyore?
Bro, get it out of his head.
Yeah, how?
Okay, maybe if I go to the other room?
To the first room.
And it'll figure it out.
Okay, I have the cog to turn down the water.
And I'll get blue.
Okay, I gotta talk to Christopher.
And then he'll tell me not to be sad anymore.
And then I'll be not sad.
See, Eeyore, it works for me!
I can't, I can't listen to him say that same thing again.
Like, I assume that like...
You know, they recorded like...
Seven dialogue...
Dialogue options for...
Christopher Robin.
You would assume that.
Because like, you know, you're gonna be meeting some...
As a child, you're gonna be meeting some...
Cheering up.
For a while.
But he literally says one thing.
And it's literally like, get over it.
Stop being sad.
And there's like other motivation speeches he can say.
Okay, we got yellow now.
We gotta pick up yellow.
Is it like...
Who was the voice actor for...
Christopher Robin?
Someone said it was like...
Someone said it was like McGregor.
Was it actually...
Him as a kid?
I was gonna say his voice acting...
Was way too expensive.
Whoever...
Whoever is Christopher Robin's voice actor...
Way too fucking expensive.
They made him record one line.
No, they made him record two lines.
The first line was like...
Silly piglet, you're just crazy.
There's nobody here.
And then...
Second one was...
Stop being sad.
That's everything they gave Christopher Robin.
That's literally all his dialogue.
Grow up, piglet.
Alright.
Open sesame.
Violin room.
Who lives here?
Oh.
Wait, can I buy a cookie?
How much money do I have?
Kick.
I do not have a lot of money.
Why am I...
Broke in Eeyore's world?
Eeyore, where the fuck...
Is all your money?
Eeyore, where is your money?
We should be close to 90.
There's like two faces I can buy here.
I don't have enough fucking music.
Not music.
I don't have enough money for it though.
I don't like this.
Yeah, that's the piano BGM.
Okay, I'm like...
I'm like four away.
I think I kicked everything.
Yeah, we gotta get the music pieces.
What the fuck are...
He didn't skip leg day.
He did not skip leg day.
That's for sure.
What the fuck?
Those legs.
Bro, he's like...
Do you see those thighs?
Holy shit.
Those are some...
Fucking thick thighs there.
God, Eeyore.
What are you dreaming of?
Okay.
Eeyore's been dreaming up some...
Okay, I don't know if you guys noticed this.
But this is all in Eeyore's head.
By the way.
This is all in his head.
I think he's been thinking about some things.
No, it's not issues.
He just...
He's an appreciator.
He appreciates certain parts.
He knows what he likes.
Okay.
Gotta scare him.
Yeah, cry.
Tell your mama.
That's right.
Cry!
Doki.
Doki, he has a rub.
Let him have this.
Doki, just let him have this!
I'm not saying...
Okay, I am judging him a little bit.
I am judging him a little bit.
He doesn't even have arms.
Okay, I got more cookies.
Does it mean I have all the cookies in this...
Oh, I guess that means I have all the cookies in this room.
I think.
Yeah, I'm just trying to get nine cookies.
So I can at least unlock one more face.
I have two faces to unlock here, but I can't afford it.
I guess if I kick this, I should be able to, right?
73, 74.
Okay, this has to be able to kick.
Yeah, I fucking knew.
I knew that's where you hide your stash.
I knew an addict like you, a cookie addict like you, I know where your stash is.
You can't hide from me.
That's fucking right.
Pay up.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we just need...
eight more.
I mean, all of these should be it.
Yeah.
Alright.
And then this should be the last one.
Okay, at least we can afford one more face.
That's good.
Alright, then we tickle the statue.
Tickle, tickle!
What?
Why are there...
I have to catch it.
Oh my god.
Why is it so fast?
I got a quarter cap him.
Alright.
Yes, we got it.
Okay, this definitely had a different team part of it.
This...
The different team definitely developed this specific level.
Yours...
Oh Eeyore, we have all the colors!
Where did you get green?
What?
Visitors?
Who?
Wait, what?
Who, Eeyore?
Oh, you don't want to tell me who?
That's alright, guess we're not good enough friends, I guess.
His demons.
Jesus.
Oh, nice.
Piglet finally got another move.
We finally use another move now.
Can we take this?
No.
Okay, we gotta go to Rue.
Hey Rue, Eeyore doesn't have you in his, like, museum.
Because he doesn't care about you.
But can we borrow your lamp?
Oh.
Oh, they're all colors now.
Oh, I don't like this.
I hate this.
Oh, this camera angle is so unsettling.
What?
There's like, left click?
Okay.
Okay, this has to be stronger though.
Yeah, it's a stronger move.
Oh my god.
This fucking angle.
Where are my peripheral vision?
My peripherals.
Oh my god.
Please.
I don't have depth perception right now.
The Dutch angle.
I don't have depth perception.
I couldn't grab anything because of the Dutch angle.
Okay.
Here we go.
I still don't know what the potion does.
Other than...
Is there anything I can kick here?
Oh, there is.
Nice.
Okay.
I want more money.
Money.
Okay, there you go.
Now I'm gonna be jacked up now.
And then we kick this one.
That's right, Eeyore.
I know where your stash is.
I'm gonna try it.
That's right.
I know where it is, Eeyore.
I try to hide the goods.
That's fucking right.
You don't hide the goods from me.
I need to get my fix.
Alright.
Let's go this way.
Oh, is there like cookies here?
Should be.
Nice.
I just want to make sure I have enough for like another move soon.
Expert, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, Derp, thank you for the super chat.
You're such a good friend of Eeyore.
Sealing all his stuff and...
Borrowing?
I was just borrowing his stuff.
I will clearly return it.
You know, in like 5 to 10 years.
Alright, Rue.
We need your lamp.
We need this.
Hand it over.
See?
Borrowing.
You know what?
I'm gonna undream himself now.
I'm just gonna undream myself.
I'm just gonna leave.
He's out.
He's not even real in his dream.
And even Dream Rue was like, I'm leaving.
They can get out of here.
Yeah.
I can't be bothered.
Because like, there's no point in fighting them, cause like, I don't get anything out of it.
No, the saddest part is the fact that he's not even real.
He's Dream Rue.
And even Dream Rue was like, fuck this shit.
Dream Rue is like, undream me now, Eeyore.
What the fuck do I do with potions?
Okay, I got the...
Okay.
Alright.
Light.
Alright, and then we gotta light this one too.
Oh wait, it was just one?
Did you get Rue's lamp?
Yeah.
It's still dark in here.
What?
Oh my god, you're so demanding.
You're so demanding.
I already did it on the mission, so it doesn't really matter.
Doors are open?
Oh, what's that?
The door!
Wait, he didn't die!
Guys, see, it wasn't murder.
Guys, I told you it wasn't murder.
He's still alive.
Wait, what?
What?
But I'm broke.
The fuck is all these?
What's the top left?
What?
What the fuck is the top left?
I don't have money!
Oh my god, what can I kick?
What can I kick?
I don't have money!
I need a fuck...
No!
What do I kick?
I didn't get...
Okay, sorry Eeyore.
I'm actually gonna leave your dream now.
I'm gonna...
Sorry, Eeyore.
You're actually on your...
I'm gonna leave your dream.
I'll come back later.
Goodbye.
I gotta go to...
Owl's dream now.
Alright, let's go to Owl's dream.
I farmed a lot of cookies, though.
That's the thing.
I don't think there's a lot of cookies left to farm.
I feel like I have to go to...
Like, I sell that one cookie here.
And then...
No, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
Yeah,
but he's like ruining the mood.
You know, that's different.
He's like...
I'm trying to fix Eeyore's depression right now.
And like...
The door's ruining the vibes.
He's like killing the vibes right now.
Gotta get out.
It's fine.
It's the same.
It's still dark.
Okay.
I mean, you're welcome to fix him.
I feel like everybody's tried.
Look.
He's gotta be able to fix himself.
Okay?
The thing is, he doesn't want to be fixed.
And that's why it's a problem.
That's the thing.
Alright, we gotta go to...
Go to eat the door.
Get the fire from...
Rue's dream.
What is Alistar's dream?
I don't remember Alistar's dream.
I just remember never...
What?
Not here?
I remember I could never finish Alistar's dream.
What is he trying to find?
His book?
Hey, Gopher!
What are you doing here?
Huh?
With what?
I feel like he never had this tick.
Like, frequently.
This is like way too much whistling.
I feel like this one's like way too many whistles.
Did he actually whistle every...
Every like...
Sentence?
I don't remember if he did.
Did he actually?
I don't remember it being this often.
I knew he whistled, but that was like...
A lot.
Oh, I should kick.
Kick!
This is the worst part of farming for cookies.
This is the worst part.
I think it just sucks it's so many cookies.
Like the power-ups.
You have to like...
Actually be actively farming them.
It's like a cookie simulator.
No!
No, it's behind a thing!
Did I farm this one yet?
No, I didn't.
Okay, I gotta make sure.
Because the next one is at like a hundred.
So I gotta make sure.
Alright, off I go.
Owl, wake up!
Owl!
Oh, I'm so strong.
I'll pick that, you're so strong.
Wait, what?
Did I not push it?
What's going on?
The fuck does that mean?
What?
I don't know what that means!
I...
What does that even mean?
Give me my cookies.
Now I'm mad.
Oh, it's like in order.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Okay, yellow.
Okay, yellow first.
That should work, right?
Okay.
No, that's not yellow, that's green.
Wait, red?
Oh, it's red.
Okay, it's red.
Oh wait, this is trial and error.
Red, yellow?
Oh, it's just backwards.
Okay, that's easy.
Look at that, I'm so smart.
Yay!
It was literally just like...
backwards.
Wait, it's locked.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why is he in a cage?
What did Owl want to do to him?
Wow.
That's a cage.
Oh.
Wait, I want to play pool.
I want to be pool bear.
Oh my god, look at him go.
I'm gonna get you.
I wonder if I can be sneaky.
Oh my god, no, I'm too hungry.
No, I'm too hungry.
Bro, what the fuck?
Wait, I'm so fucked up.
I'm too hungry.
I'm so fucked up.
Oh my god.
I'm so messed up.
Jesus Christ.
I got to the other side.
You're wrong.
You're right.
Okay, so...
Pool bear!
Not again!
Where do I go?
That's a maze.
Oh, I'm fucked.
Oh no.
No!
No, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
No, am I gonna have to do it from the beginning?
I got cornered.
How the fuck do I get out?
Oh my god.
That really doesn't like...
Oh, you don't, Piglet.
You don't have to.
Oh, so this is why you never finished it.
No, thank you.
Thank you.
This is not fair!
This is actually...
Oh my god.
Okay, we go this way.
We go this way.
Run, Pool Bear, run!
Run!
Oh my god.
See, we made it.
We made it a lot faster, Pooh.
Oh my god.
We hope you'll run faster.
We do it enough.
The worst part is this area.
This area is the worst part.
Because it's like, you can get cornered so easily because you don't know...
Like, what is this bullshit?
Are you serious?
That's actually bullshit!
That's bullshit!
Like, where do I go?
Turn!
No, I have to do this again.
Keep running.
Thank you for the super chat.
Bro, this is so bullshit!
Okay.
Oh my god, here I go again.
Stop!
Get away from me!
Oh, body.
Oh my god.
Where do I go?
They all want a piece of me!
Waddle away, waddle waddle.
Why did they make this part so hard?
Why did they...
Why specifically this part?!
Oh my god!
Where do I waddle?
And waddle waddle.
And he waddled away.
Waddle waddle.
Get waddling, Pooh Bear!
Get waddling!
Oh my god!
We did it!
We made it!
And then he got caught after.
He...
He actually...
Bro, fuck that level!
Oh, he's alive!
Oh yeah, no, there's a lot.
Good luck, Piglet.
He almost died, Piglet.
He did it for you!
He did it all for you!
He live hungry and traumatized.
Now he's gonna eat his feelings away.
Alright.
Okay, now I don't have to fucking worry anymore.
Now it's not that bad.
I can actually fight back.
Alright, finally.
That's right, Huffalumps!
I can fight back!
Be gone!
Key?
Where would the key be?
I'm just gonna try and see if I can find a key here.
Oh.
That's fine.
These guys don't have as much HP as the other levels, so like, I'm not too worried.
Alright.
Pull those ears.
They like, die faster.
Okay.
Um.
I should've gave a little bit more space.
Okay.
Okay!
Nevermind.
Guess it wasn't.
Wait, is there like, any cookies here though?
I don't know if there's any cookies here.
Look!
He was so fast!
I couldn't juke him!
It was so fast!
I was just a little guy.
Oh no, I'm scared.
Okay, so there should be...
Okay, there should be a key somewhere here.
Alright.
This should be enough space, right?
Yeah!
There should be enough space as long as he doesn't close his eyes.
We should be fine.
Don't close your eyes!
That's illegal.
Nice.
Okay, we did it.
Oh, by the way, I forgot to... I think like, I was in middle of top... Oh, wait.
Oh!
I just got killed though.
Oh my god.
Okay, I had to kill the other guy.
Okay.
But yeah, yesterday I watched Wicked.
Um...
I think watching in 3D was a mistake.
I haven't watched a movie in like, years.
Like, at a theater.
I haven't watched a movie in a theater in a long, long time.
And like, the thing is, normal standard doesn't have like... Why 3D?
Because like, I wanted like, um, IMAX and like, it's 3D.
So...
Yeah, so like...
Yeah, and then like, the colors were so... I realized that the colors were so like, washed out because of the 3D glasses.
Because I haven't watched a 3D movie in a long time.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here?
Wait, how did you get here with digging?
We're hovering!
Yeah.
Yeah, they're like, washed out.
What?
I know!
Wait, children and chess?
Yes!
Yep.
Oh.
Okay.
Here.
Let's do this.
Wait, is this...
That's the bishop right here.
I guess that's the pawn, right?
This is the pawn, so this is the castle.
Okay.
I feel like I was just teaching children, like...
There you go.
Yay!
We did it!
Yeah, but like, how the fuck are the kids... Some kids don't play chess?
Like...
Some kids don't play chess.
How the fuck do they know?
Yeah!
What is he gonna say to me?
Yeah, he doesn't... No, I played like...
I learned chess in middle school.
God.
This game is not tied towards... Wait, what about the key?
There's no key here.
What about the key?
I thought I was supposed to get a key.
What?
Yeah, but like, a lot of children don't learn chess at the...
No, no, there was like, um...
The thing in the center.
They're like, when you grab a key, then you can open this.
Middle schoolers are tweens.
I was a tween in middle school.
Get it right.
This!
Okay, I must have to like...
What's the word?
Travel back to it.
I was in a chess club in elementary school.
Nerd!
That's right.
That's where I said it.
Yeah, okay, nerd.
You know what I played as a child?
I played Chinese chess.
The one with like, the tiger...
The...
I just remembered the tiger piece.
I played Chinese chess as a child.
Which apparently is harder than regular chess because it's like...
There's just so many rules to it.
Oh, he's scared.
That's right.
Yeah, I remembered.
I used to play that a lot as a kid.
And I also played the star marble game too.
Oh, that's cute!
That's like a Mickey Mouse ink.
Nerd!
No, he closed his eyes!
The one with the star shape.
I don't remember what it was called.
Oh, it's a treasure map.
What?
What the fuck do I do here?
That one was fun.
I love playing that.
I love playing that in Chinese chess.
It was like one of my favorite board games.
I remember like, in a before times I was like, does anyone play any of these?
Because I want to do a collab stream of it and no one knew how to play.
It's like, I found a website where you can play online.
I was like, everyone, I really want to stream this game.
Does anyone know how to play?
Because I didn't want to play it.
No one knew how.
Oh.
What?
Did he call me Kinglet?
I'm literally a pig.
A memory book?
Oh my god.
He has amnesia.
His biggest fear is dementia?
And then Rue's biggest fear is losing his fucking balls?
Like, understand, Winnie's biggest... Winnie the Pooh I like Winnie's.
Yeah, he's my...
Homies call him by his first name.
Oh my god.
I like how that's so fucking sad.
Like, Rue's biggest fear is losing his balls.
And then like...
Wait, what's this?
Oh.
Oh, this is where I have to buy.
And then like, Eeyore is just being like...
Eeyore is a lot of things, to be fair.
Like...
Eeyore is a lot of things.
He's like, biggest fear about.
But like, Pooh is like, starving.
Pooh Bear is just like, being hungry.
Give me your fucking money.
How am I gonna get money for like, Eeyore's level?
Oh my god.
God damn it!
Stupid Eeyore!
Stupid fucking door!
God damn it.
Okay, we can burn stuff down.
Ow, I'm hungry.
God damn it!
I have to grind so many cookies!
Okay, we can burn this though.
Alright, burn that.
Wax you.
Do not like that sound effect at all.
Guys, how long is this game?
Can I even finish it?
This game is E for everyone.
Well, I never finished it.
Cause I got too scared.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Five hours.
That's wonderful.
To be fair, we got a little behind.
Because of my one hour life update.
Plus, Owl knowing what I did.
And softlocking me.
Now, Tigger and Rabbit.
What?
Oh no, math.
Oh no.
I clearly have to move this, right?
Yeah.
So I can get up here.
Yay!
And then, what do I do here?
Oh, here.
I have to...
Come on.
Come on, Piglet.
You have to push it.
To the blowy thing.
Key!
That's the...
The museum thing.
No, I'm definitely not smart.
Well, I mean, he's losing his memory.
But now I am.
Alexander, welcome to the farm!
Welcome, welcome!
And then...
What do I do with the eraser?
I guess I push it out?
I don't know what else to do with it.
Is there gonna be like a diving board?
I know if I push it up here, like...
It's gonna...
I can't push it back.
Oh, I found the painting!
Yes, family!
Okay, we have one of the paintings.
Okay.
What do I have?
Okay, I have fire.
Okay.
Okay, wait, I should be able to kick something.
Wait, is there anything I can kick here?
Please, I need cookies.
Oh my god, I'm gonna scratch myself.
Please, sir.
Oh my god, don't make me scratch myself.
I need cookies, come on, please.
Just one cookie.
Please, I need just one.
Just one little cookie.
Come on.
Come on, sir.
Why is there no cookies here?
Cookie, please.
Oh my god, there's no cookies here!
I got the cookie itch.
I'm too far gone.
Blake!
Where?
Give me that cookie.
Okay, there we go.
We got one cookie here.
Where are the other cookies?
Do we have extra?
Oh my god, I missed three here.
87...
88...
Okay, we need two more.
Okay, one more.
Please, sir.
Thank you.
Okay, I got the cookies here.
Come on, we almost can't.
We need 11 more and I can afford another face.
I need another face, please.
They're gonna kill my family.
I just need one more face.
Please.
Just one more.
Okay, nice.
They're after...
They're after my family.
Please.
They have my...
Who are they?
I can't say.
I can't say who they are.
All I know is that...
Is that...
They're in these booths.
This is the only way to communicate with them.
This is the only way I can communicate with them.
This is the only way.
They know.
Okay, can I keep this?
I fucking knew it.
I knew that was a secret cookie stash.
I knew it.
You don't need this.
You don't even have your memories.
Oh my god, that's actually so fucked.
Give me the cookie.
Oh my god, I just need one.
Just need one.
Oh thank god.
103.
Nice.
Okay, we got another...
Stash.
Christopher Robin doesn't understand the concept of currency.
All he knows is cookies.
This is all that is mine.
This is all mine.
Alright, I deposited my cookies into the box.
What is your message?
What the fuck?
What does the nose do?
The cookie monster Bobby.
Oh my god, guys.
I talked to the wrong monster.
Alright, we got...
We still need more cookies for...
I think the worst part is that we need to find enough for...
For the Eeyore level.
Because we don't have enough cookies for that.
So we might have to go back to Pooh Bear's level.
I did not farm enough there.
I fucking was so casual about it.
I was like, I don't need cookies there.
Everything will be fine.
But everything is not fine.
I learned the hard way that everything is not dodgeable.
I learned the extra hard way.
Things are not okay.
Okay, I think these guys die forever.
If I scare them in time.
Oh shit.
As I said, if I scare them in time.
Okay.
That should be two.
It's like two hits.
Hufflepuffs are two hits and woozles are three.
That's like the worst part.
Woozles are too strong.
There we go.
That's the key.
Should be another painting, right?
No, it's the treasure map.
Okay, we got the treasure map.
So...
We just have to go...
Let's go back up.
There's a lot of like backtracking here.
If I go to the left side.
Oh, if you collect their bottles, they stay gone?
Who's not gonna collect their bottles though?
I guess the child.
Cause the child would be like, bye!
Which makes sense.
The child wouldn't care.
Alright.
We go here.
Yeah,
I'm like absorbing their soul.
I keep it in my little collection.
Never letting them out.
So they'll live there forever.
Almost burned the map down.
No, nobody will get the treasure.
Alright.
Out we go.
Why is everybody hyped this game?
Cause this was 20 years ago and like a game normally would not be like this 20 years ago.
Oh my god.
It's so big.
Okay, is there rocks here?
Is there a cookie stash?
Oh, there has.
That tree.
That tree's a cookie stash.
Give me.
No!
My cookies!
Oh, he died so fast!
Oh, he's a weak man.
Okay, that's good.
No!
Oh, hey, dad.
Wait, what?
I have to be very brave?
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's the ultimate attack!
That's right!
Turn into a potion!
Let me absorb your soul.
Oh, shit.
Nevermind.
Let me get you first.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
I'm so strong now.
Give me your soul.
Oh!
I just have to kill them!
Technically, they're not dead.
If you think about it, chat.
I just have their souls, which is different.
Okay, so I need like...
Oh, my God.
It's alright.
It's just one cookie.
It's not gonna affect the whole game, right?
You know it all adds up.
No, no, no, no.
It's just one.
If I just leave one unattended...
That's fine.
It's not gonna add up because it's only one cookie that I forgot to get.
That sounds like a big...
Sounds like a...
Oh, I have to scare the tree.
Alright.
It's time to scare the tree.
Okay, tree.
That's right.
I'm here to scare you.
Oh.
Boo!
Goodbye, nature.
We don't need oxygen.
Oh, hey.
There's a painting here.
How do I get the painting down?
Oh, shit!
Magic!
Oh.
I don't need...
Who cares about the treasure?
Okay.
Piglet, you fool!
There could be cookies in there!
Piglet, there could be cookies!
Piglet, no!
There could be cookies!
Oh my god.
You stupid pig.
I missed out on the biggest cookie stash of my life.
My fucking cookies.
Piglet's a better person than me.
Piglet, our addiction!
We can't fix our problems if we don't get the cookies!
Oh, we already got a lot of cookies in this level.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Now he'll remember.
Because we have both paintings now.
He's gonna remember.
Alright, owl.
I got the paintings.
Here you go.
Wait, I gotta put it in the...
I'll put it in here first.
Alright, owl.
I got your... Oh!
I got your great-grandpa owl.
Do you remember them now?
Oh, he doesn't remember.
Wait, but he remembers the Book of Memories?
You don't remember anything else but a fucking book?
Goddamn nerd.
I can play as a rat?!
Oh my god.
Sorry, Sharko.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
What?
You scared?
Oh, you want me to go in?
What?
Wait, and everybody called me a coward?!
Fucking little bitch.
Fine.
Oh my god.
Maybe I should just leave you like this.
Maybe I should.
I could live in your house because you don't know what's going on.
I could just be like, this is my house because you don't even know where you are.
And I'll put you in a home.
That's right.
That's right, owl.
I'm gonna fucking put you in a home.
That's so evil.
Eldritch Liam, don't leave me caught.
I say in front of 3,000 plus people.
Oh shit.
Wait, what?
Maybe Gopher can just dig it out.
Oh, I can light this!
No one will ever know.
Oh.
Okay, I'm timed.
That's fine.
It's just light three candles anyway, right?
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Oh, it's four.
I can't count.
I'm trying to light it as fast as I can!
Whoa!
Okay, done.
We got it.
I'm gonna use the bathroom then while you fucking watch this cutscene.
I'll be right back.
I hydrated a lot because I can't find a fucking doctor!
Lore?
Okay, I'll stay.
I'll stay.
I'll stay for the lore.
Your book, owl.
Your memory book.
That's it?
I did it.
You didn't even read it!
How do you get your memory back?
I did it.
Bro, what the fuck?
All he had to do was read.
All he...
There you go.
There you go, owl.
You don't have to be afraid of losing your memory!
Don't have to be afraid of dementia!
Congratulations!
We fixed it!
We fixed it.
If only it was that simple, right?
Okay, I need to use the bathroom for real though.
I'll be right back.
I'm back!
Thank you for the gifted ships!
Thank you!
It's time to farm.
We don't have enough cookies.
225?!
Okay, let's go to Pooh Bear's.
Let's go to Pooh Bear's dream first.
Oh my god.
How is there 225 cookies?
Mama Kanga...
We farmed that shit for so long.
Mrs. Kanga does not...
Mrs. Kanga kept being like, Wow, please clean up the room.
Of course I washed my hands, guys.
Wait, Bravest of the...
That's fucking right!
Get out of here!
That's right!
Oh, do they just run away?
No, it's fine.
I'm just gonna...
What am I supposed to do with this?
Bro, I can't even eat them like Pac-Man!
What am I supposed to do with this information?
Oh, they just fucking die.
Wait, they just die?
Like, what?
I mean, that's fine.
That's fine with me.
They just disappear.
They got heart attack, guys.
They got heart attack.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
Which one has to be cookies?
Okay, I got that.
I knew it.
I knew there was a cookie stash here.
I think I need like 110.
Cause like, I don't have a lot of...
Is this a cookie stash?
Yeah, I need 110 left.
Come on, please.
They're gonna cut off my legs.
Please.
I just need...
I need 110.
They're gonna cut off my legs.
They're gonna cut off my toes.
Please.
I borrowed from the cookie monster.
It's too late for me.
Is this this cookie?
No.
Where are there more cookies?
What kidneys?
I'm literally a toy.
I'm made of stuffing, chat.
What do you mean?
Kidneys.
I'm literally a plush toy.
What do you mean?
I borrowed from the Sesame Street Mafia.
It's too late for me.
There's no hope.
Alright, do you think these guys are gonna have a heart attack?
Rose, thank you!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
That's fucking right.
It's time to get a heart attack while I fucking get some cookies.
Oh, nice.
One cookie.
That's fucking right.
Oh, it does do it!
Oh, it does!
I don't know why it didn't give me...
They didn't let me have a Pac-Man thing earlier.
Okay, is that all of it?
No, it's fine.
They're not gonna give me cookies.
What's the point?
Just let him have a heart attack.
Okay.
Just...
Just let them have heart attacks.
They don't matter to me.
Nice.
Oh, thank God.
That's right, you don't matter.
The cookies matter more.
Okay, let's see.
Oh my God, thank God.
Thank fucking God!
Thank you!
Okay.
Is that all of it?
Yes, I know I missed one.
But like, is that all that matters?
I already got these.
John, thank you for the super chat.
No, you don't understand.
Don't you think it's time to understand?
It's not a me issue.
It's a cookie.
It's their fault.
It's not me.
It's them.
Oh, I guess because I didn't catch them, they'll always spawn.
Because I don't have his soul.
Get in my stomach right now.
That's fucking right.
Collectible!
I see.
It's a collectible.
It's for an achievement.
Their souls are collectibles.
Yeah.
That's why I have to catch them.
That makes sense.
Australian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait until Doki finds out about cookie clicker.
Bro, okay.
I'm gonna say it.
People who play cookie clicker mostly use an auto clicker.
Not even.
They don't even do it legit.
That's right.
I said it.
I fucking kicked for real.
I don't need no auto clicker.
All I need are these legs.
That's all I need.
I'm literally fucking kicking with my legs.
Look at this.
This is no auto clicker.
This is literally my hands right now.
Look at that.
That's right.
Run!
That's fucking right.
Get in my stomach, you weasel.
Easy.
Okay, I got that already.
What have I not kicked?
What have I not kicked yet?
No, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This?
No?
Wait, I think I'm almost done.
If I go to Rue's place, I might be able to grab more cookies.
Alright, it's time to leave this dream.
Yes.
I'm done with your dream, Pooh Bear.
I'm done invading it.
Alright.
I'm done playing with you.
I already got most of it.
Look, I just need 155 and it's not worth it.
195?
Where?
Where the fuck was 195?
Where the fuck was that?
Okay, I know for sure they're not here.
I cleaned up her house.
Oh no, there's no ones and twos.
There's no way.
I left like a couple of ones and twos.
I refuse to believe it.
It's fine, let them run.
I have five cookies to find.
Let them run.
Literally, this is more...
Literally, this is more important right now.
I won't watch them die.
Yeah.
Oh, you're gonna die soon.
That's right.
You're gonna get a heart attack.
Oh wait, cookies.
Nice.
Okay, we're missing literally 10 more and we should be good.
Okay, 15 more actually.
I got them.
Okay, we got this.
God dammit, there has to be more.
Where's the cookie fun?
Oh wait, there's a rock here.
That has to be where the cookies are.
Okay, that's...
I already kicked this.
Oh, I knew it!
I can feel the cookies.
Nice.
Okay, 10 more.
10 more and we'll be free.
We'll be free for another level until the rabbit and tiger level.
And then they're gonna make me grab more cookies.
Then they're gonna make me grab more.
I can feel it.
Rabbit and tiger are gonna be like, it's time.
It's time to learn more feet.
It's time to learn more moves.
Piglet.
Okay.
Nice.
78.
Okay, we need two.
We literally need two.
We just gotta grab two and we're free.
We're free from the cookie mafia.
Are we ever really free?
Are we ever really free from the cookie mafia?
It's time to farm more cookies.
There you go.
No.
What more do you want from me?
What more do you want?
Please.
I've kicked my whole life.
What else is there to kick?
I need two.
I just need two.
Please.
This one's harder.
Because it's like...
What?
What did I not kick yet?
Oh my God.
I feel like I kicked everything.
I feel like I'm just getting out-kicked.
Maybe like...
I don't know.
Maybe it's like...
Wait, is there anything here?
Oh my God, please.
There has to be one more place I haven't kicked yet.
Oh my God.
I can't even reach the cloud.
Piglet, please.
I need you to- I need you to find me more cookies.
Piglet.
Piglet, please.
Please, Piglet.
Oh my God, I'm out-kicked.
I kicked everything.
Oh my God.
There's one cookie.
This is it.
Okay, we'll kill him real quick.
Okay, we'll leave him out of his misery too.
Get over here.
Asshole.
That's what you- Oh, that's the 3-4-1 special right here.
Oh.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, you think you can get away?
You think you can get over here?
Get over here.
I'm gonna get you.
Come on.
Oh, you think you can run away?
Oh!
That's fucking right.
You can't run away.
You can't run away from me.
Hehehehehe.
Just remember, you can never run away from the kicker.
There has to be one more cookie.
I literally need one.
Where are all the cookies- Where are all the one cookies I left?
Like, they have to be, like, secret areas or some shit.
I felt like I kicked everything around here.
Okay, maybe, like, maybe there's one in Rue's area.
There has to be.
I was not farming a lot.
I definitely could've farmed more.
Oh, there we go.
The one cookie I left out.
Oh, shit.
Okay, maybe it does add up.
I did kick the mailbox.
That was the first thing I did.
What's the point of this game?
Cookies.
It's just- It's just cookies.
Hehehehehe.
It's just fucking cookies, man.
There's two here.
I'm just gonna get these in advance, cause I know- I know that rabbit level is gonna be like, Wow, Piglet!
You need more fucking faces!
Okay, let's leave.
We can leave now.
Instead of cookie clicker, we're cookie kicker.
Alright, this is it, Eeyore.
I'm coming back.
Don't worry, Eeyore!
Don't worry!
I'm coming back!
Eeyore!
Homies never forget a homie.
Oh no, he's having night terrors.
Don't worry, Eeyore!
I'm here to save you!
Oh no, I've been- I've been coughing for two plus months now.
I've been- I've been trying to get to a doctor, but...
We have a doctor shortage.
Oh yeah!
If you- If you just watch the first hour of the VOD, and you'll understand.
Oh man.
Wait, he's still alive?
What the fuck was the point?
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I've been like drinking a lot of tea.
I basically like drink tea every day.
Like the ones- Yeah, the herbal teas for the throat.
It's like special tea just for the throat.
Guys, I'm still too weak.
That's why I've been using the bathroom a lot.
Oh, I forgot to like heat up my kettle for more water.
Goddammit.
Oh my god, please.
Okay, I gotta learn a scary face and the music room.
Cause that's the one I didn't buy a face.
Alright, give me a sec.
I'll come back soon, Mr. Dwarf!
I'll come back!
You sure it's not COVID?
Apparently to the nurse, it's not urgent enough.
So like, fuck me, I guess.
She literally was like, it's not urgent enough.
So like, you just gotta figure this out yourself.
Alright, let's see.
Can I kick this chair?
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I'm gonna kick everything.
I'm desperate.
I'm so desperate.
I've been through so much.
I've kicked this door.
Oh my god, of course it's one.
Just go to- yeah.
The thing is, we don't have walk-in clinics here anymore.
We have to make an appointment to a walk-in clinic.
And I called eight different clinics.
Alright, what kind of face do I get this time?
Jesus Christ, what?
That's some Junji Ito shit right there.
That's like when the dad was like- No, what was it?
There was like a specific panel where one of them just opens his fucking mouth like that.
Piglet, I don't think- Piglet, I don't think that's normal.
A pig should not be able to do that, Piglet.
Okay, I can scare the door.
This is it.
I'm gonna kill a door.
Alright, get over here, door.
I'm fucking- get over here.
Get over here, I'm fucking- I'm so scary.
I'm so fucking scary now.
This is it.
That's right!
I learned a new move!
I found the cookies!
Okay.
Cookie Mafia sent me.
Whoa.
Eeyore?
Eeyore!
Give me your hand!
Okay.
Eeyore didn't give a fuck.
This is why I didn't have my statue.
What the fuck?
He didn't help.
Guys, remember that he didn't even help.
Oh shit.
Okay, this is fine.
This is enough spaces.
That's right.
Get bubbled!
Oh.
Okay.
He doesn't care.
Get bubbled again!
That's right.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Three times?
Three times the charm?
It's like Mario.
It's like Mario!
Three times the charm.
What?
Is this hole made for me?
Another one?
Piglet learns bubble.
But now he's in color.
So like...
Wait, does that mean I have to fight them three times?
Or two times?
Okay, I'm just gonna run a little bit.
There we go.
That's right.
Get over here.
I'm fast enough.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Maybe I'm not fast enough.
How do I do worse?
Okay, that's fine.
I just gotta get to the third one.
Nice.
Three times the charm.
Okay.
But stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
For your penchant for cruelty and bullying nerds.
I was wondering if you ever wanted to play bully.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The reason why I've never streamed bully is because I played bully all the way to the end.
That was like one of the few...
That was one of the few games I've actually played.
Like...
Not when they first came out, but it was like the scholarship edition.
I got the scholarship when I was like...
Not a streamer.
So I'm not going in blind.
I've actually played it to the end.
It's one of the few story games I've actually played.
Because normally I don't play story mode games.
It's a good game.
I actually enjoyed it.
But you're not getting a...
What's the word called?
Blind reaction.
Because I know the entire story in the game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That should be it, right?
It's three tries.
I've already progressed further than Little Doki.
This is the furthest I've ever progressed.
Loco, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My Oshi playing the spooky, dooky, Silent Hill.
This truly will add more to Papa's garden.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is it.
I did it, Eeyore.
Oh, Eeyore, it's only you.
Sorry to have frightened you.
Seems to happen a lot.
Oh no, it's alright.
I'm very happy to see you.
Well, thanks for saying that.
I want to thank you, Piglet.
You brought the colors back to my dream.
There's no physics.
You lit the candles again.
Are you happy now?
There are no more Heffalumps in my house.
Because of me, Eeyore?
Yup.
And you did it all just to help me.
Thanks for cheering me up.
Your half-depression cured!
You're welcome, Eeyore.
I did it!
He still has a million other problems, like homelessness, but...
I cured his depression.
Despite his fears, if you wish hard enough for something, you can make your wish come true.
That is definitely not the story.
He still fucking lives in that fucking stick house.
At least he doesn't have night terrors anymore.
Having all the colors back kinda turns a grey day sunny.
Thanks for your help, Piglet.
We fixed him!
We fucking did it!
All he has to do is wish hard enough.
Oh no!
There's no point in painting, Tigger!
It's raining!
His stripes!
Now you're not special.
Wait, that's what he's sad about?
Wait, what are his fears?
My carrots!
Okay, like...
Eeyore has an actual real...
Eeyore and an owl have real fears.
Not gonna lie.
Like...
Owl and like...
Eeyore have like actual nightmares.
The rest is like...
Carrots.
And then the other is like...
I'm not special because I have no...
Stripes.
Alright, rabbit, I'm coming in.
I guess like his individuality, but he's the only one!
He doesn't have income!
It's just...
I guess like starvation?
Okay, I can see rabbit's fear as starvation.
Cause like it's literally his food.
Rabbit's fear is literally starving to death.
Don't worry, I got you!
Rabbit!
And that's exactly what he dreamt about.
What a disaster!
Use your hands!
Oh no!
I'll pull you!
Oh no, he's having a panic attack.
I'm gonna pull it!
Oh, but sorry, I just know how to use my legs!
Sorry, rabbit!
I just... I'm just a leg guy!
Using my arms?
What is that?
Oh my god, you collect all of this.
I need a hundred and twenty cookies!
Oh no!
I got a farm.
We should get gopher in here though.
Maybe gopher knows what to do.
Okay, I can dig you out!
Got it!
Don't worry, rabbit!
I know what to do!
Get over here!
Oh, I just said rabbit's fat.
I'm sorry.
I didn't say it.
The narrator said it.
Rabbit.
I thought I could just dig you out!
That's fucked up, narrator!
He's just big bone!
That's fucked up!
I would've done it, rabbit!
Guess not.
Guess the shovel is not used for digging.
Who would've thought?
You would think a shovel is there just to dig somebody out.
Alright, let's see.
Can I open this door?
I guess the giant beans are locked.
Alright, I guess we go this way, then.
Hello?
Heffalumps?
Woozles?
Oh.
In the 500 B.C., there were heffalumps and woozles.
I wonder why they never give them pants.
Whoops!
Whoops, went the wrong way.
Why do they never give them pants?
Ancient cave paintings.
I understand the gloves, because gloves are easy to animate, but what about pants?
Why is there always a shirt?
Okay, one of them has to... come on.
One of them has to have cookies.
There's 200 cookies.
I know there's 200 cookies!
Okay, I have to fight them.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
Wait, no!
No!
Okay, there we go.
That's fine.
Okay.
We got the bubbles.
Is this okay?
Can you die?
Is it three hits?
Oh, it's three hits!
It's three hits!
No, no, no!
Run!
Okay.
That's fine.
I can do this in three moves.
It should be it.
Okay.
I now know that you can use X to move away.
Oh, thank God there's a cookie.
We gotta grab the cookie, though.
We're like a hundred away.
Just a hundred away, guys!
Just a hundred more cookies!
Okay.
Nice and easy.
Alright.
Is that one, two hits?
God damn it!
You're so tanky!
We gotta learn a new move!
They're all three hits now.
Alright, nice.
And then...
That should be all of them.
Nice.
We've destroyed history.
That's good.
Destroyed natural artifacts.
We're gonna erase the Hufflepuffs and Wuzzles' history.
And their existence, so they never existed.
And they were never real, guys.
The Hufflepuffs and Wuzzles?
The fuck is that?
I didn't know Piglet was pretty.
Oh, shit.
We're gonna wipe them out.
Rewrite history.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I think this part is the worst.
Because I know, I know that fucking door is gonna be like, you gotta learn three fucking moves!
I can feel it.
I can feel that door.
I can feel that door fucking coming at me and be like, you didn't learn enough moves!
No one's fucked up!
I basically entered people's dreams to make them like me more.
I manipulated them.
You think about it.
Yoki, this is a kid's game.
Yeah, so?
I'm gonna put my ideals onto it.
Well, seems to me it's missing a cog.
I'm sure I've got one in a shower.
Yeah, I'm brainwashing them to make them like me.
I don't have the key.
Okay.
Oh, he doesn't have the key.
Kick the bucket.
Okay, I need you guys to know, I disassociate when the gopher talks.
I really do.
I feel like he's whistling more than usual.
Oh, nice.
I got grain.
Ah, seeds!
Me too!
I just...
I literally just... I don't acknowledge him as a...
I don't even see him as an NPC.
Okay.
I need like...
I need to find a thing over there.
Wait, then what do I have?
I have the shovel.
What?
What do I do with that?
Hmm...
There's like nothing here though.
It's like the only place I can go.
I guess there's something behind me.
Do I go back to rabbit?
No, I don't want to talk to gopher.
Don't do that to me.
Don't say that.
I feel like...
He used to not whistle every sentence.
There was a bird door?
No, that's the bean door.
That's a...
That's a bean door.
Where would I go?
Is there...
Oh!
Wait, no, that's just the exit.
Huh?
Every line?
I don't remember that.
It's definitely more annoying.
You want my bird seed?
Okay.
What did I do?
He doesn't want me to dig him out.
What?
The Hufflepuff was?
Wait, was there another door?
Was there?
I thought it was just one door.
Okay, there's that big one.
Oh, what the fuck?
There's another door!
Here, here's my bird seed.
Wait, what?
Take my seed.
What?
But I have it right here!
Who has my fucking key?
Who has it?
Gopher, who has it?
I'm gonna dig you out of this hole.
Tell me where they are.
Eh, quite a problem, those birds.
How do I get to the birds?
Where do I drop these seeds?
I just want my cheese.
Okay, I thought I tried to drop the seeds outside, but they had to stand in a specific area.
Because they wouldn't let me drop the seeds.
My cheese.
Ah, the fucking little smiley friends.
Take my seed!
Seed!
Please!
He's bottom right!
Where's his whore?
Okay, the tree was blocking the path.
Okay,
you how?
How would I like know?
How?
I'm fucking, oh no.
Oh no, he's gonna Oh no, oh no.
No!
He fucking scared me.
Now I'm scared.
Now I'm a scared little guy.
Oh, there's Tigger.
Wait, okay.
Oh wait, I'm gonna get rid of these guys.
Okay.
Booga booga booga.
Okay, that should be the last hit.
Alright, nice.
Consume.
Okay, now I'm a little bit scared though.
Okay, don't worry, I can still kick this tree.
I might be scared, but I can still kick.
Got this.
What else could be cookies?
This has to be cookies.
No!
Tigger, stop talking to me!
Tigger, get out of here!
I need to get more cookies!
Okay guys, give me a sec.
No, oh my god.
Tempo, message me.
Work time.
Give me a sec.
Okay, I hope that the Huffle Dumps- oh my god.
Don't worry, we'll be fine.
He's not gonna come up to me, right?
If we stand here, we'll be fine.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, here we go.
This is fine.
Alright, this is it.
FUCK!
No!
I'm too scared!
Okay, the worst part is that I'm slowly walking to me.
This is so fucked.
This is actually so fucked.
Oh my god!
Bro!
Why does he like slowly walk up to me?!
That's- Oh my god.
That's so fucking bad!
I just have to let him walk up to me.
Like, he doesn't even run!
This is so dead.
Okay.
Oh no, I didn't- Okay, I hope he doesn't say the same thing where he was like oh, you should've been there.
There were 200 million Huffle Dumps.
Okay.
That was torture.
Just watching him like slowly walk up.
That was actually torture.
How the fuck do I- okay.
No way.
Okay.
How do I do that, right?
This should work.
No way he walks back- oh, thank fucking god.
Oh my god, I hate you, Tigger.
Alright.
Okay.
We got this one.
The fucking Metal Gear Solid shit.
We did it!
Okay, we didn't do it.
Come on!
God, what?!
What?!
Excuse me?!
Okay.
Okay, I guess I won't- I don't know what his plan was.
Guys, the worst part is I have to do this all over again if I fuck this up.
If I fuck this up, I have to do this all over again.
If I fuck this up, I-
No way he sees me here, right?
Oh-oh.
Okay.
I don't know if this is a corner.
Is this a corner?
Is this a safety corner?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if this is a safety corner, but I'm gonna go here.
I fucking- I hope this is safe.
No!
It looked like a safety corner!
It actually looked like a safety corner!
How is it not a safety corner?
Oh my god, three dozen?!
Oh my god!
Are you mad?!
Oh my god, that's crazy!
Oh my god, I'm gonna be so mad.
I fucking hate you, Tigger.
Show some respect!
He's a vetter.
Oh my god.
Please!
Is this a corner?
A safety corner?
No.
No, this is not fair!
This is not fair!
There's no safety corners!
Look, he looks in that corner!
If I ran there, he would have looked in that corner.
If I ran there, he would have looked in that corner, chat.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
The stealth machine.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Yeah, that's right, but he goes left, so I have to go backwards.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Fucking hate stealth so much.
I hate stealth.
Okay.
This is it.
I just gotta go for it.
The moment...
He goes back!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh.
Go, go, go, go, go, Tinker, go!
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god!
Oh.
Thank you for the superchat.
This game got stealth mechanics like Metal Gear Solid.
This game has every type of genre, from horror to tactical espionage.
I did it.
Piglet.
After fighting 5,000 Hufflelumps and 100,000 Weasels.
I did it, Piglet.
I'm no hero.
Okay, please go back.
We gotta get those cookies, Piglet.
Piglet, don't cross the lake.
We gotta get those cookies!
Use those legs of yours!
That's right.
Okay, 51.
We have more to go.
We have so much more to go, Piglet.
It's not over.
It's not fucking over.
We gotta figure out where would they live.
Where would the cookies live?
Nice.
Thank god, okay.
Nice, alright.
This is fine.
We just gotta find Christopher Robin to tell us to stop being sad, and then we'll be better.
We just need to find Robin.
Please, I need the motivation, that one thing you can only, one line you recorded in that studio.
Oh, there he is!
There's Croaky!
Wait, that shit looks like Croaky.
There he is!
He stole the fucking key!
We gotta get every Croaky macrocheat.
My god, why did it go so far this time?
Get over here.
I ain't afraid.
This is so trippy.
Every time I fight this guy...
Jesus Christ.
Oh, no!
Okay, the upside down one was fucking crazy.
What?
Again?
Oh my god.
I can't tell.
I can't tell!
Oh, thank god he's weak though, at least.
I'm just happy he's weak.
Thank fucking god.
Okay, no cookies.
Cookies?
No?
No cookies?
Cookies?
No?
Cookies!
Yay!
Okay, nice.
We got cookies.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, here!
Here's my seed.
Eat, you fat whore.
Eat.
It's okay.
We're close like that.
Croaky and I are close, I can say that.
That's right.
Guys.
Guys, I've been playing for five hours.
I'm not okay right now.
I'm not okay.
Oh my god.
I've been kicking for so long.
I've owned so many cookies in the Cookie Mafia.
I'm not okay.
All I do is kick for cookies.
I just kick for cookies.
I'm not okay.
I'm not okay, guys.
No!
My one cookie.
Okay.
Alright.
We'll go this way.
Is there anything I need to get from here, though?
Because I feel like...
I feel like...
I don't know.
Because I just needed the key, right?
So what would...
Oh my god, that means I have to backtrack back here.
I guess the cookies... Oh my god, thank you.
Oh my god, thank you, Christopher.
Now I'm happy.
Depression gone now.
It's that easy.
Not depressed now.
Let's go.
What the fuck is like...
Oh my god.
What?
This?
Okay.
Okay, who wants to fight me?
Nice.
Alright.
Get out!
Get out, weasel!
Oh shit.
Okay, one more.
Last one.
Nice.
Okay.
I don't have to worry about him anymore.
Get him.
Wait, what?
Who wants to fight me?
Oh, him.
Look at me.
Look at me!
Okay, that's fine.
I'll just get the cookie.
Look at me!
Fight me!
Alright.
Oh fuck.
Oh no.
I cannot look upside down!
I can't look upside down!
My head can't comprehend!
Okay, this one I can.
Okay.
Oh no.
Alright, there you go.
Oh wait, what?
Oh shit, okay.
Gotta run.
Okay.
That should give me enough steps.
That's like one more life.
Oh no.
Nice, I got it.
I can't read opposite!
That's it!
It's like when you try to look mirrored.
It like fucks with my head.
I don't know if I'm gonna...
I don't know if I can make it.
There's just so...
many cookies!
Alright, is that all of it?
No, there's more.
There has to be these.
I fucking knew it.
I'm like a professional now.
I can tell where all the cookies are.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Wait, what's this?
Should I say I'm dumb?
Okay, it is backtracking.
I fucking knew it.
I knew this was a backtrack area.
I was like...
Okay, so we still have this area.
We got the key.
So I was like...
Of course.
No, I'm not gonna check the...
I'm not gonna check the other elephant.
There's no need to.
I need to get the...
I need to open the key.
In the birdseed area.
And then use that and get whatever he has.
And then go back...
Backtrack back to that area.
Because I'm assuming the birdseed area...
Is gonna open whatever the fuck I need to do.
In the other area.
Okay.
Oh, he's back?
Why are you back?
Nobody likes you.
Get out!
That's why you're trying to love yourself.
Because nobody else would give you that love.
Not even your mom.
Okay, I don't need aimbot anymore.
Alright, let's go back here.
I like him.
No you don't.
You're just saying that because you feel bad.
That's even worse.
That's pity.
That's just...
Pity.
Alright.
I'll go this way.
It's because you feel bad for them.
Wait.
Do I need to go this way?
What's the key for?
Oh wait, it's for the birdseed area.
I went the wrong way.
Loli, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's called...
Petsy.
But you don't like him for him.
You like him because you feel bad for him.
That's worse.
You don't like him as a person.
It's just because you feel bad.
I'm sure the most down bad dragoons will kill you.
That's what she said.
Thank you for the superchat, Loli.
Thank you.
Alright.
Where are we now?
Oh.
What the fuck?
You too, rabbit?
What is up with...
Get over here.
Oh my god.
You're so fast.
Oh fuck.
Okay, we got one of them.
That's why I got you.
That's right.
Okay, we gotta corner you now.
No.
Get in the corner.
No, don't go there.
Oh my god.
He juked me.
What is this AI?
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this AI?
You're so fast.
Okay, I got him in this corner.
It's over.
No way.
No fucking way.
I can't run faster than this.
Look at the legs.
Look at his legs.
Are you serious?
Thank you.
This is fucked up.
This is actually fucked up.
I can't run faster.
Oh my god.
You're such a bitch.
This is actually torture.
This is torture.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Oh my god.
Okay, last one.
I need to take them into a fucking...
I'm gonna lead them to this corner.
This is the dream corner right there.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
The right corner was the only corner.
Okay, we got...
By combining all the baby cogs, we made a big cog.
What did you do to the babies, Doki?
What did you do to them?
We got a big cog now.
You know what?
If I sacrifice all the babies, the mama cog will come out.
How many of these will it take?
The two?
No.
The three?
Okay, it's three.
Okay, that's good.
Okay, it's not as bad.
Three is not as bad.
Come on, fight me.
Okay, how many steps is this?
Okay, we can do it.
Oh, we can still do it.
We can still do it.
Okay.
Okay, third one.
I swear, is there a level after Tigger?
I swear to God.
I...
I'm about to give a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, absorb.
Kick.
Now it's kicking time.
I don't have 120.
I'm sorry, Cookie Mafia.
I'm almost there, please.
I just need three more days.
Please, Cookie Mafia.
You know I'm good for it.
Just give me three more days.
I feel like I was like Piglet.
Must buy all the faces.
I just need an extension.
Please don't break my ankles.
Please, I just...
I'm almost there.
I just need 18 more.
You know I'm good for it, sir.
You know I'm good for it.
They got a reputation.
They can't make exceptions, Doki.
If they make an exception for you, they gotta make exceptions for other people.
They can't do that.
You know I'm good for it, though.
When have I ever let you down?
Where's the last one?
I'm gonna kick one more, but which one?
Them's the rules.
I'm missing one...
There's like one more box.
But which one?
Is this?
No.
This is what happens when you owe so much, Cookies.
When you've been farming for Cookies for what feels like 20 years.
It's not this.
I already farmed that, too.
Yeah, farm these.
Oh, what?
Wait, I thought I already kicked this.
Alright, we got this area.
I thought I kicked that already.
I was so confused.
Okay, I can't buy a face yet, guys.
I don't have enough.
130?!
They used to go by tens!
What?
When did they increase their interest rate?
They increased their interest rate.
I'm so poor.
Oh my god.
What?
Okay, I'll put a cog in.
I didn't give you a pool bear.
That's interest.
That's collateral.
I'm gonna take my chances.
Okay.
Yay!
That should be it.
We did it.
Yeah, because you didn't do it.
Yeah, because you didn't, gopher.
You couldn't even press buttons!
You know, gopher could literally stood at one of the handles, but he didn't.
He was just a supervisor and he gets paid ten times more than me.
I love capitalism.
I love it so much.
I did it, rabbit.
What do I do with the shovel?
Oh, what?
Oh, it's extracting!
Gopher makes a dollar, I make a dime.
That's why I kick for cookies on company time!
That's so good!
What do you mean?
That's my life right there.
I got another key!
Key!
That's too real.
That's too fucking real.
I got in.
Gopher makes a dollar, I make a dime.
That's why I kick for cookies on company time.
It's time to- oh my god, there's fucking robots now?!
It's time to kick.
It's kicking time.
Oh my god, let's go gambling!
You can never escape gambling.
What the fuck?!
Okay.
I'm stoking!
That's
actually bullshit!
That's actually gotcha!
This is bullshit.
Oh my god, I'm literally guessing.
Bro, they aren't- oh my- It's more than two!
It's more than two!
That's actually- oh thank god he's slow.
Thank god he's slow.
How is a kid gonna- Oh my god, how is this kid gonna fucking function in society after this?
That's crazy.
We actually- actually, let's go gambling!
Okay.
Alright.
Next time you have to pull out a guitar.
Oh my god, bro.
Fuck you!
No!
Okay, what's this?
Oh no.
Okay.
Okay, at least it's one.
This guy gave me one.
Aw, dang it.
The worst part is that he takes three moves.
I think if I- Okay.
I think if I get the- the other expression, it'll take less moves.
But like, this is- this is not it.
This is- Oh my god, I got so lucky.
Oh yeah, I got so lucky, RNG.
It's teaching kids how to camp.
No!
What does this do?
Oh, okay.
I just have to do all of this.
Just gotta press all the buttons.
Okay, and then...
Assume like, if I do all the buttons, it'll open up.
Oh!
Wait, am I gonna see the giant?
Wait, do I go up?
It's kick time.
Kick.
It's time for my favorite job.
It's all I have.
Kick.
I need a hundred and twenty.
Please, I need to feed my children.
My children, me, myself, and I, and dad too.
It named them all me in an afterthought.
Oh yeah, and also my dog.
Okay, we still need one more.
Is this tomato?
I fucking knew it.
That tomato looks- the tomatoes look very, very, like...
Like, they don't look too good.
No, I'm just...
I'm so tired of kicking.
They were not meant to kick for so long.
Kick.
Tree?
I'm missing one more.
The key?
How many more keys are there?
Kick.
What am I missing?
Like, that tomato looks red.
But then the other tomatoes...
Like, what happened to this tomato?
Oh, there's another box of tomatoes.
I fucking knew it.
Okay.
We did it.
Alright, up we go.
We gotta climb up.
It's Jack and the Beanstalk.
It's Jack and the Beanstalk time.
What the fuck?
Where are we?
Oh no.
Oh no, not this one.
No.
I'm too stupid.
My mind can't comprehend.
No, I never made it to this level, guys.
I told you guys.
Oh no, not the upside down.
This is the first time I got the upside down.
I never made it this far.
The furthest I've ever gone to was...
was Owl's level.
How are we up in this?
Is this like Rabbit's Secret Stash?
Wait, can I not push this?
Okay, we push this.
Wait, where do we push?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, it has to be empty.
Okay, I got it.
There has to be kickers here.
There has to be.
Are you telling me there's no cookies in the sky?
There's no cookies in the sky.
Why?
I can't believe it.
A world without cookies?
How could Rabbit do this to me?
How could he?
Okay, that needs a...
Where do I need the crank for?
Guys, which area needed the crank?
Was it the bridge?
I thought the bridge was the key.
I don't remember which area needed the crank.
Crank that soldier boy.
It's over there, Doki.
Just over there.
Was it the...
Tigger area?
Was it a cell forest?
I thought that needed a key.
I guess it needed a crank.
Okay.
Are you fucking all?
That's okay, I'm faster.
I can't.
I can't deal with these guys.
That reminds me of that video from Half-Life of the guy editing... Crank that soldier.
Crank that soldier boy.
I did the soldier.
I recorded...
When we were there doing rehearsals in our 3D, we had time to do recordings and stuff for shorts and things.
I told you guys, it was during the off collab with Mint when we were talking about it.
We were like, oh we have time, let's just record some stuff for shorts.
For me, I did soldier boy.
Plus other...
I did like dumb meme dances.
Mint did like actual dances.
I was like, Crank that soldier boy.
And Superman.
I don't want any less from you.
I won't tell you guys about the other dances, but I'll just let you guys know.
Because I already talked about it in the off collab with Mint.
I did soldier boy.
I'm cranking it.
Guys.
I gotta crank that soldier boy.
I gotta represent.
What?
What is that sound?
Is that a new enemy?
Oh fuck no, it's Gamba.
It's fucking Gamba.
Oh no, that's not what I wanted.
Okay.
No, get the Gamba out of here.
I think the worst part is that I have to do the arrows as well.
Yeah, by the way, Mint and I are gonna do a concert.
Oh no.
It's like almost- Oh my god, he's next to me.
It's like, we've been like three weeks I think.
Yeah.
Stop laughing at me, it makes me sad.
Wait, is he actually slow?
Okay, I'm gonna skip this guy.
No, fuck this guy.
The only reason why I wanna do it is just for the cookies, so I have time for cookies.
I don't like feeling pressured in my hunt for- in my quest to not get my- not get myself beat up by the cookie mafia.
You don't wanna piss off cookie monster.
He's seen things.
He's seen stuff.
Oh my god, get away from me!
No!
Oh no.
No, he laughed at me and I got sad.
He's done things.
Quick.
No, I'm sad.
What's this?
Oh, it's a key.
Oh, it's for the barn.
Okay, I'm gonna fucking spend my cookies too.
Why do I still have the shovel?
I have picked up the shovel and I still have not used the shovel.
Like, what was the point?
There's like one more area that I need to kick.
That's it, I'm getting you out of this game.
Stop!
Stop laughing at me!
I just wanna go gambling.
What is this RNG?
Okay.
Oh, let me out.
Let me out.
No.
Stop!
I had a spooky laugh.
I can't.
No, I can't.
Get away from me!
Get away!
Get fucking free!
Oh my god!
He's a freak!
Now it's a horror game.
Told you he's a freak.
Alright,
we got him.
Oh my god, the freak is dead.
Where could the last...
I didn't grab all the cookies in this level.
There's a missing cookie here.
What could give a cookie?
I already kicked that area.
Is it this?
No.
Where could the last cookie be?
I hate this.
I hate hunting for cookies.
Please, one cookie.
I know I'm missing a cookie stash somewhere.
Where is it?
Where are you hiding the stash?
Wait, I can use...
Wait, I actually can use the shovel?
There's no way.
By the river?
Where?
No, there's no way.
You guys are fucking with me.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
You guys are fucking with me.
There's no way.
I knew it.
You guys were... Oh my god.
You guys trolled me so hard.
I just... I give up.
It's just one stash.
It's not gonna affect my entire game.
There is?
Think near the...
There's no way.
Which rock?
No, you're fucking with me.
There's no way.
I knew it.
I knew you guys were...
You guys are just making me so paranoid.
I fucking knew there was nothing.
I...
I knew it.
I knew there was nothing here.
It's just...
I don't care.
It's just one area.
It's just...
There's... Oh my god.
It doesn't matter.
I'm gonna buy...
I'm gonna buy the...
I'm gonna buy the face.
I might be a little stronger if I buy that extra face.
I need...
Christopher Robin, where's the...
Christopher Robin, cheer me up.
Tell me to not be sad anymore.
Thank you, Robin.
I really appreciate you telling me not to be sad anymore.
Okay, we gotta buy the...
The face.
Where was the face again?
It was in the cog room, but...
Was it in the bird room?
I think it was, right?
Thank you, Christopher Robin.
So inspirational.
That was so inspirational.
I really appreciate it.
I should be faster than these guys.
There we go.
It's okay.
Leave me alone.
Zonerman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Moments like this are why it's good to be a masochist in Doki's chat when she's afraid and she starts calling the monster a freak.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know if I read your super chat, but thank you for the super chat.
Can't wait for the concert.
I'll see you guys later.
Gotta go.
Thank you.
I hope you guys like the concert.
I really do.
We're working really hard for it.
Oh my god, no!
Yes,
I don't want to do a part two.
I just want to finish it all and let go.
I have too many series.
I still didn't finish Silent Hill.
It should be with the bird.
I think.
Right?
The bird area.
I have Rabbit and Tigger.
Maybe Tigger's level is really, really short.
You guys don't know that.
Like, I'm pretty sure it could be really, really short, guys.
No, I didn't learn the face!
No!
I'll never know.
I didn't see the face.
Oh, I bet it was very scary.
I bet it was so scary.
Okay.
I'll go this way.
It says the longest- Oh, thank god, this is the longest level.
I fucking knew it.
Okay, I'll go this way and then into the barn.
Of course, Rabbit has the most fucking worries here.
Alright.
Open the door.
Door open.
Okay, door open.
I'm sorry.
Door open now.
You can't just interact and the door just magically opens.
I gotta fucking take my hand out.
Okay.
Okay, we're almost there.
Almost finished with Rabbit.
And then everybody will love me again.
Oh, okay.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I have to fight these guys.
Alright, maybe we'll see our new move.
What the fu- Okay, this has to be.
What the fu- Okay.
Okay.
Alright, Piglet.
What?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can use the shovel!
It's time!
I got rocks!
Wow!
I got
- I did it!
We used the fucking stupid fucking shovel.
We did it.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay, we turn this on.
Oh my god.
We've been holding that shovel since the beginning of this level.
This godforsaken- Oh, cookies.
I get angry, but I see cookies and now I'm happy.
It's just that easy.
Oh, cookies.
Now I'm not angry anymore.
Alright,
nice.
Okay, so we're still missing- Oh no, is he blocking?
Is he blocking the last cookie area?
Is it him?
No, I just missed one here.
No, I- I missed a lot more than one apparently.
Maybe it's this?
No, no, please Mr. Elephant, please.
Please, Mr. Elephant, please.
Mr. Elephant, sir.
Me have my cookie!
Oh, nice.
Oh!
Where's the exit?
Please, Elephant, I don't know where the exit is!
Where is it?
Oh, it must be over here.
Right?
Oh, there it is, there it is.
A hundred left.
We just need a hundred.
And then we're free.
We're free from the cookie mafia.
He'll hurt me no more.
He can't hurt me no more.
Tinker has twelve rooms?!
Oh my god.
What are you- What's wrong with you?
Oh.
We did it, rabbit!
Okay.
Wait, what gate?
Oh, this gate?
I got you.
Oh.
Okay, you could've been more specific, rabbit.
This is not on me.
You literally said push it.
Alright, I push.
Wow, wow!
I saw that!
That was passive aggressive.
I fucking saw that.
Rabbit, wrong lever.
Literally, he pointed it to me.
Ali, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Pooh's stream was so short and easy.
How did it end up like this?
Pooh's only worry is that he doesn't get honey and starve.
Rabbit's worry is that he'll just starve.
But like, more stressed out because he's an adult.
Oh, so that's what all the logs was for.
Oh no.
No!
I don't wanna fight you!
Also, are you welcome?
Oh no.
Are you welcome to tomato farm?
Welcome, welcome.
I fucked up.
This has to be two tries, right?
Oh nice.
Okay, now he's just two.
Because I got stronger.
Okay, push.
I did it, rabbit!
Are you proud of me?
Okay, he's not yet.
He's not looking.
Rabbit, rabbit!
Look, look!
Look, rabbit!
Oh, that felt very Asian.
That felt...
Guys, I don't think he's...
No.
My mom's not proud of me, guys.
It wasn't an A+.
Mom, I got an A!
Mom, look!
Why are you tricking me?
Why don't you do it?
That's so ungrateful.
Rabbit, you're so good at it.
You do the thing.
Wings, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, blonde lady streaming piglet?
I'm too silver for this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't even kick for cookies.
I kicked for cookies.
I already finished all these cookies.
Oh, fucking yeah, the five other times I did it for you!
Don't worry, rabbit!
I'm doing it!
For free!
In your dream.
It's not even a real life.
It's not even real life.
Even in a dream, you're an asshole.
Just remember that.
Even in a dream, you're unlikable.
All he's good for is providing honey for Pooh Bear.
That's right, I said it.
He adds no value to the story.
Rabbit is nobody's favorite character.
Piglet, please!
You must help me out of this cart!
Oh, yeah?
Oh my god, so demanding.
I like rabbit.
What do you like about him?
I don't even know.
It's pity.
He keeps it real.
Rabbit is like Charisma Blackhole.
His entire purpose in winning the Pooh is to provide Winnie honey.
So he doesn't starve.
If we take away rabbit, there's no logical reason for Pooh Bear to even be alive.
Because who's going to fucking feed him?
30 cookies?!
I don't know.
I don't care anymore.
I'm not going to go back that far.
How did I miss 30 fucking cookies?
There's no second though.
There's only one Tigger.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
People like Eeyore more than rabbit.
Are you?
Oh wait.
I know why you're in this stream.
No, you're not special now.
Time to buy a new Tigger plushie.
He looks like Cheeto.
That's what I'm saying.
He's not unique anymore.
He just looks like Cheeto.
The fuck is this angle?
Cookies.
Alas.
Guys, it's almost over.
We almost farmed all the cookies.
We have one last scary face to buy.
There's no way.
It has to...
Oh my god, I swear if it tells me to buy two faces.
I swear to god, I'm gonna...
I swear, I'm gonna fucking...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're 1000 Acre Woods, guys.
Of course, we kick everything we see for cookies.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Soon we'll be free.
Soon I'll pay up my debt from the cookie mafia.
And then I'm gonna...
And then I'm gonna be free.
Mr. Cookie...
Mr. Cookie Monster.
Leave me be.
As we all know, if you pay off your debts, you can leave, right?
Right?
That's how it goes.
Oh no.
No, not Gamba Man.
Gamba Man, no!
Gamba Man!
Gamba Man, leave me alone!
Please!
Okay.
Yeah, we leave after the last job, right?
That's how it works, right?
Oh no.
Oh no, okay.
Is that it?
Is it two?
Oh, thank god, it's two.
Okay.
Cookie!
Oh my god, I hope it's just one face.
Oh, please.
Please just be one.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, Big Man.
No, Big Man, no.
Don't, Big Man, leave me alone.
Please.
No.
Please, I'm just a little pig.
I can't.
Devlin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tigger, losing his stripes?
Besides fear of losing his rank, he had it worse since stripes signify rank.
It just reminded his time in the Great Tigger War.
Without the stripes, he just...
He thinks it just means it was never worth it.
Everything he did in the Great Tigger War never mattered and he doesn't want to think about that.
That's right, fight me!
Fight me!
Fudge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, what?
Wait, I'm not even...
No, I think Rabbit is even worse.
No, no, no.
Rabbit is even worse than Lion King.
At least in Lion King, they knew what they were doing when they drew Nala.
When they did the animation with Nala and those eyes, they knew exactly what the fuck they were doing.
Rabbit, you have no excuse.
You have...
You have no excuse for Rabbit.
They knew what they were doing with Kovu and Nala.
Kovu and...
Kiara and Nala, they knew exactly what they were doing.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, PTSD.
Fudge, I need you to explain.
What about Rabbit?
I think that just means you're...
I think that means you're a gilf.
You're into gilfs.
Oh, that's freaky.
That's actually freaky.
What am I supposed to do here?
We don't know how.
You know how.
You're embarrassed.
Oh, there you go.
You just gotta turn it.
What kind of puzzle is this?
You just turn it.
I mean, look at Rabbit.
It tells us a lot about...
If you got your awakening from Rabbit, it tells us a lot.
What the fuck?
Why are you here?
Oh, there.
What are you doing here?
I'm looking for Tigger.
But if you are...
I saw him just a bit ago.
At least, I think it was him.
Before you see him, the Tigger I think I saw did not have any stripes.
So I'm not sure...
That's mean.
Now he's definitely gonna be depressed now.
Yeah, I'm gonna steal this.
XD
Oh, full?
Oh my god, I'm stealing this.
You don't need it anyway, Pooh Bear.
No!
Don't do this to me!
And then it goes this far?
God, I hate it when that happens.
Oh, I'm gonna steal some balloons.
There must be something with this.
Why is this here?
There has to be.
This looks so weird.
It's so out of place.
Is it up top?
There has to be something up top.
There's no cookies here.
Yeah, I think something up... Oh, the hole!
I almost forgot about the hole.
Fudge!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I ain't gonna speak for my kid self.
Kid Fudge Top was weird, but at least he doesn't...
Thank you for the super chat!
Who are you implying does that?
Garfield is pure.
XD
Oh, up there?
Rue, I should adopt his son?
Yeah, cheer him up.
What the fuck?
Rue!
Fucking help!
Rue, I can't jump that high!
I'm a pig!
He's like...
Oops, sorry, I forgot you're a...
I forgot you can't do that.
Okay, give me a sec, little guy.
Please!
What the fuck?
Why am I using a weak-ass move?
Oh god, oh god, oh god!
No!
Please!
Oh my god, please!
Wait, there's two!
Okay, that's fine.
I can kill him.
Okay.
Rue just said skill issue.
Literally, he could've helped.
He did not have to do that.
He could've jumped.
Look, the thing is...
He could've jumped to the top.
Held his head up.
Oh, but he's a child.
I don't know if he could do that, but...
He could've actually easily picked me up.
Okay.
Okay, this should kill him.
This should kill him.
Nice.
Consume.
Alright, I got it.
Is there anything I'm missing?
Cookies!
Oh my god, we're so close!
We're almost free!
From the cookie den!
We're almost free from the cookie den!
There's so many cookies!
Oh my god, look at all these cookies!
Oh, it's okay!
We just need 100 and 100 and 450.
It's okay, we'll get there.
We're gonna be free.
One last drop and he'll let me go for sure.
That's what the mafia is really known for.
If you pay off your debt, you won't be dragged back in.
That's what we all know about the mafia.
Okay.
Can I use my balloon?
Balloon?
Oh,
the bridge!
Okay, we gotta go past the bridge.
I mean, I could go fly there!
Technically, I could use it to fly a little bit!
Okay, we gotta go cross the bridge.
Time to cross that bridge!
Okay, it's like this way.
I can't wait.
I cannot wait to get more cookies!
I can't wait to get more cookies!
No, and then I'm gonna go straight.
I'm gonna go clean.
I've learned.
Guys...
Guys, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go clean after this.
No more cookies after.
I don't have any withdrawals!
Whatsoever!
Oh, nice.
Wait, what?
I could've just thrown a rock at it.
Dead chat!
Thank you for the super chat!
It would be funny if someone ate all the cookies before you could pay the debt.
I've never played this game, but maybe.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that.
I'm sweeping.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
I did it.
I did chores even in a dream.
There has to be something for this.
I can feel it.
Kick!
Please tell me it's just one face.
Wait, there's a gardener now?
Oh no.
Oh no, he seems very big.
God, we're so close.
Okay, we gotta get rid of the gardener.
We gotta get rid of the help.
What?
He can obscure vision?
How do you see my UI?
He has the power of breaking the fourth wall.
Oh my god.
The power of breaking the fourth wall.
Nice.
Fence.
No.
Get the next...
Oh, there's an amusement park here.
There's a bench, I knew it.
I knew the bench had that cookie.
I knew it.
I can feel it.
Can I go through here?
Yeah!
What?
No.
But all I have are cookies.
That's my only form of currency.
What do you mean?
In a dream?
I have no money?
Who's gonna catch me?
There's no one there.
There's no one there to catch me.
I'll just jump over it.
Maybe it'll take my money.
Wait, what's this?
This isn't a shovel?
Oh my god, it's a nice shovel.
They get to reuse the acid.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
They get to reuse the acid.
Let's fucking go!
Wait, where do I go?
Wait, where do I go though?
What needed a shovel?
I don't remember what area.
Oh, the snow!
The snow!
Okay,
that makes sense though.
That was a lot of people's awakening.
No, no, no.
Rabbit was the weird one, Sharko.
No, you're normal.
Sharko.
No, it's one of the top five.
It's like Kovu.
It's like what?
Kovu, Robin Hood.
The Robin Hood movie.
Because it was like Robin Hood and his girlfriend.
It's okay.
It's like Lion King.
Okay, I'm just going to say the movies.
It's not just Simba.
It's like Simba, Kovu, and Kiara.
So like Lion King, Robin Hood.
Yeah, the Disney Robin Hood movie.
Lola Bunny, Gadget.
From Rescue Rangers.
And then...
I don't remember who are the other...
I know that's like the top five for people.
You seem to know a lot.
Because I remember I googled like...
What was it?
There was like a Disney...
It was like hottest Disney character.
Somebody made a list.
Of like hottest Disney characters.
And it was like one of them.
And I remember like she put a dog on it.
And I was like what the fuck?
Oh shit.
Oh fuck, oh no.
Am I faster than these guys?
I don't know.
We are going to find out today.
Oh yeah, nice.
I don't remember why I googled it.
I think like somebody asked.
And then like let's google it.
Yeah and Jessica Rabbit too.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Alright Rue, it took me five hours.
But I'm coming over.
Thanks for helping me.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Bateman Tigger.
Sabertooth.
Oh fucking, there it is.
There it is.
How much do I need to pay?
140, okay.
Not that bad.
Wait, I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
Wait, Rabbit?
Wait, everybody's here.
Fudge Top, look!
Look, Fudge Top!
You can warm him up right now!
Oh, Fudge Top is looking for some rare seed.
Why is he shaking like that?
Because he knows Fudge Top is watching.
He should have told me about the rabbit.
Doki, please.
Jaden, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki plays Pooh Bear.
Kids game combo.
Without any doubt.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh wait, what did I get?
What is that?
Oh, maybe that's what he's looking for.
What the fuck, Pooh Bear?
What are you doing here?
How did you get here?
Okay, Pooh Bear.
What?
Why would I need to feed him honey?
Okay, I'm gonna give Rabbit his little thing.
Here's your seed.
It's a very big seed.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Seized Doki.
Okay, I can finally buy this face.
You're just gonna let me do that footage?
In front of me?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
My pig's like, yay!
What the fuck was that?
Oh my god.
Okay, that looks like a fucking horror show right there.
But he had to, like, have his mouth open too.
Alright, here's the honey, Pooh Bear.
What?
He doesn't know I stole the honey from him.
That's why he's hungry.
Okay, Pooh Bear.
Not gonna lie, Piglet voice acting sounds like it hurts.
That's like Pooh, at least he's like, oh such as rude.
But like, Piglet sounds like, strained.
Yeah, sounds like it would hurt to do.
Why do they all sound so pathetic?
Cause they're fucking a children's imagination.
Like, it's not pathetic, it's childlike wonder.
You just, you've just lost it.
Oh no, not again.
No, no, don't do this to me.
I'm just a little guy.
Oh my god.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's been six hours and Dragoons are openly admitting their childhood awakenings.
You gotta finish this game fast before we confess to our crimes.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Sharko, I sent my super chat to try and take Keats off Fudge only for Doki to call me normal.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Okay, so run!
And he gave me away.
Well, I shall just have to try it again.
It's okay, Pooh.
I can try to find another way.
But Piglet, I'm your friend, and we shall help each other.
This time, I'll be sure to make it.
Gax, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Today's my birthday, I'm mostly a lurker, but I've decided to try and...
No, oh no, oh no, oh no, no, no!
Dad, don't do this to me!
I'm so slow!
I'm being slow!
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday...
No, no, no, that's Fudge!
No, that's so Fudge, I didn't know where to go!
Happy birthday, dear Gax!
Happy birthday to you, yeah!
Where the fuck is the... oh, it's over here, it's over here.
It's over here.
Okay, I decided to try and interact with the community more.
So right now, thank you all for the fun moments these past years, and I hope you have fun.
Thank you again for every super chat, and again, happy birthday to you!
Okay, why does this seem... look at him!
What do you mean, why does this seem so difficult?
Look at him!
Oh, fucking... no, it's a maze?!
Oh my god, it's a...
Guys, goodbye.
Wait, unless... no!
This is so...
Oh my god!
Why is this one so hard?!
I looked into their eyes.
Oh my god, I looked into their eyes, I know it was over.
Oh my god.
Okay, if I do it here...
Okay.
Okay, I just need to juke them like this.
And then... surely...
That's good, we're doing it!
Oh my god, the vibrations!
No, they're on my trail!
Okay.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Some of these faces remind me of those Brickrock Source films.
Yeah, it does, it looks like those Scout faces.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Okay, we figured this one out.
But how the fuck do we do the second one?!
And the hard part is like, it's trial and error, because it's a maze.
That's the hard part.
That's the fucked up part, that they put me through this.
Unless...
Can I go back?
I don't know what to do!
I don't know how to do this!
I don't know!
I just...
Like, where do I go?!
Okay.
Alright, here we go again.
Here we go again.
I don't know.
I just, I don't know.
I feel like every...
Oh my god, no, this is bad.
This is so bad.
No!
God!
Oh my god, please!
The poopy, please!
Why don't you go a little faster?!
Why aren't you just a little faster?
Don't ask for much.
I just want you to be a little faster.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta loop-de-loop.
We gotta loop-de-loop.
We gotta loop-de- Oh shit, the pee's coming!
He's on my tail!
He's literally...
Holy fuck!
He's literally on my tail!
He's like, I'm gonna get you.
I'm gonna get you.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get you!
Please, not the pee's!
Oh my god.
The poo-ga-tory.
This is actually the poo-ga-tory right now.
I don't know.
I don't know how to get out of here.
Can I be faster than this guy?
Is it possible?
Is it-
Wowee!
Wowee, I did it!
Oh my god, it was so tight!
It was actually so close!
Holy shit, I swear it was like one or two pixels.
Alright.
This is it.
I'm free.
Freedom!
Oh my god, the frame-perfect dodge.
And he waddled away.
Are you serious?
No!
That's actually- Oh, thank god there's none of them.
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna say, that's actually fucking evil.
That would've been so evil.
Huh?
What?
What do you mean?
Pooh bear?
Oh, I found another pot of honey, okay.
So I did nothing?
Oh my god.
I did all that?
I did all that for nothing?
No, I didn't!
I didn't!
Why does he wear pants?
Why the fuck is Piglet just fucking not even a shirt?
He's leaving it all hanging out.
Oh my god.
Okay,
but like...
Her eyes, though.
What does rabbit have?
Like...
Like, it makes sense.
Her eyes.
What the fuck does rabbit have?
Like...
You don't understand.
Rabbit's a hag.
Guys, I need to know.
Is there another face that I have to...
Guys, no, this is very important, guys.
Is there another face?
Guys, I need to know.
Guys, you have to...
Guys, do I need to buy another face?
This determines if I start collecting more cookies.
I don't care if it's spoilers.
Guys, this is very important.
Yes!
I'll never get that.
That's 150!
That's 100.
I'm not gonna make it.
Oh my god.
This is actual hell.
Water away.
Okay, the heat pack should work.
Cough, cough, cough.
One more.
Oh, another bean.
Okay, we gotta get rid of these guys.
Because there's more cookies.
Oh god, I hate that face.
I actually hate it.
It looks so fucking wrong.
Oh my god.
130 left to go.
Yeah, that looks like Uzumaki's shit.
It literally looks like Junji Ito.
Oh my god, no, I thought it was one last job.
Guys, this time, the one last job.
They promised me it's the last one and then they'll stop to let go of my family.
I'm just gonna run past this and then start kicking.
I'm gonna kick!
There has to be one!
What's this?
Okay, I don't have...
Okay.
Okay, I thought this was an extra hidden thing.
Watching, thank you for the super chat, thank you!
Okay, I gotta get rid of these guys.
Oh my god, I still...
There's so many...
There's so many faces!
Faces!
So random, thank you for the super chat, thank you!
Gotta collect faces.
Gotta work.
Work for the boss.
Gotta make him happy.
Kick.
At least these are like one hit now.
Thank god.
Gonna cry, cry you little bitch.
I fucking...
We're almost to the end.
Kick!
Oh no.
There has to be one more for me to kick.
Fight me!
Fight, turn, look at me!
That's right.
I'm not afraid of you.
I'm gonna start kicking.
That's fucking right.
Disappear!
Okay.
Kick.
What the fuck is this BGM?
Like...
Like why is it like...
This BGM is like extra freaky.
Is none of... wait.
Oh my god, I'm like literally missing one.
Missing the kick, I don't know which one.
Oh my cursor, sorry.
Alright.
Where did they come from?
Oh, we have to kill them.
For the bridge.
Okay, nice.
We got their soul.
Okay, soul acquired.
Kick.
There has to be some cookies here.
Someone must have a stash somewhere.
Look at me!
Look at me.
I'm desperate.
I have nothing to lose anymore.
Wait, what?
Oh...
No, no, no, no, no!
God damn it!
I just wanted to kick.
I literally missed one, because I was button mashing.
Alright, nice.
Wait, how did you get here, Rue?
Wait, did you jump all the way back there?
What do you need me for?
Wait a minute.
Rue...
What did you need me here for anyway?
If you're just gonna jump over here...
Rue...
That's when you talk to Christopher and be happy again.
Alright.
Okay, let's kick this.
Kick.
Alright.
Kick!
Oh my God.
100 more, guys.
Wilkie, welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
100 more.
We're almost out, guys.
We're almost out.
Is there a tree I can kick here?
Oh wait, there is a tree over there.
Be happy, don't be sad.
What do I do with him?
Can I get out of the tree?
Okay, nice.
Yeah.
Nice, and then this has to be where some cookies are.
Nice.
90.
90 left.
Hello, Rue.
It's nice of you to not wait for me.
Oh, we need a whoopee flower?
Say no more.
Look what I've got here, Rue.
That's right.
I'm a hero.
And then a rain cloud shows up because...
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, that's...
Rue.
You can jump.
But I know you won't do that because you don't do physical labor.
Yes, don't worry, Rue.
Just watch.
Yeah, just stand there.
Yeah, that's fine.
Uncle Piglet's gonna do this all by himself.
That's fine.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is Piglet wearing a modified version?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh wait, no.
I already got all the cookies, right?
In this area?
Because it's all blurring together already.
I don't remember.
Okay, up we go.
Whoa.
No, it was Death Note.
But like...
Okay, so like when you grow- Okay, so like...
When you grow up with like...
You know, fanfiction.net and like Tumblr...
And like stuff like that.
It's not about the awakening.
It's about what- It's about...
Chips.
It's about chipping.
It's about lemons and limes.
Forever.
Why is he smiling?
Piglet, why are you smiling?
Piglet's just like...
Oh my gosh.
It's so sad that you lost your stripes.
Wow, Tiggy.
It's so sad.
My God.
That's so unfortunate for you.
Bro.
Like, his smile.
Did you see that smile?
It's so...
It was so like...
It was definitely not a sympathetic smile.
Oh, 100%.
I don't care about the plot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And I was like...
Like, fanfiction.net?
Are you...
A lot of people lied about their age on those websites.
I hate Slowburn.
Slowburn was not it for me.
Okay, since you guys revealed stuff...
So like, when I was like...
When I see like a fanfiction...
What the fuck?
Okay, not this.
Okay, so like...
So like...
I was like...
I was just like...
Okay, I don't care about the Slowburn.
Yeah?
And I see a fanfiction that I might like.
I'll reveal this about myself because we're...
Almost 7 hours deep into this fucking game.
I would be like...
Ctrl-F...
Kiss.
And then I got what I wanted.
I got what I need.
That's all it took.
I was just like...
Yup.
Yeah, but like...
Some people might not have heard about it.
Some people might not have known.
What do I need a magnet for?
Wait, what?
Guys, what would the magnet be?
Darkblade, thank you for the superchat thing.
Thank you.
That's why you never reveal anything embarrassing to Doki.
Unless you want her to use it against you.
I learned this very early on.
Thank you for the superchat thing.
Thank you.
Oh, the dart!
I remember now.
It's the dart.
Um, sir, thank you for the superchat thing.
Thank you.
That's right.
Piglet, point and laugh at Tony the Tigerless over there.
Thank you for the superchat thing.
Thank you.
Budge, thank you for the superchat thing.
I remember my Inuyasha face for fanfics.
One-shot lemons were the best, but my mom did wonder why I was using her work.
But people be like...
When I tell people I like reading.
They don't know what I was reading.
Okay, this soundtrack is so unnerving.
CM.
Jayden, thank you for the superchat thing.
Thank you.
New opener idea.
Who would you read?
Slowbird?
Nobody.
Who the f...
I can't deal with Slowbird.
I was like...
If I want to see them like fucking slowly fall in love.
I'll fucking watch the show and then be delusional with my headcanons.
I'll watch whatever like show, movie, or video game they're from.
I'm here for the action.
If I see Slowbird...
Okay, this is how I choose Slowbird.
I would be like...
I'd be like...
Okay, Slowbird...
Slowbird story that has a lot of kudos.
That's a lot of love on it.
And then this is what I did.
These were my tricks.
Tips and tricks.
But I don't do that anymore.
Because like...
I want to say I grew up out of it.
I think I definitely grew out of it.
But I would like...
I'd press...
Okay, this is for an archive of our own.
Entire work...
Control F...
Kiss.
Skip everything and get right to it.
There's like...
30 chapters...
Entire work...
Control F...
Kiss.
Okay, there we go.
That's...
I don't need to know the context.
I can gather the context from the summary.
As well...
I can literally gather the context from the...
The story summary.
And just realize they're right there.
And they made it.
They...
They made it.
I was on a mission.
Alright.
Poke.
I did it.
I fixed your house, Tigger.
Stray, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
When the Powerpuff Girls defeated the Rowdy Ruff boys by giving them the eyes and kissing them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, I fixed your house.
I don't need to charge you.
I'd be fucked if I charged you.
This is your dream.
No, I had a shot if I really wanted to get that over with fast.
It wasn't Control F, Kiss.
But I don't want to talk about that.
What my shot was.
Because that one is embarrassing.
Okay, let me get more water.
I'll be right back.
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, we need to know that pro strats don't hold out on to us.
If you are an avid reader.
You already know the strat.
You don't need me to tell you.
If you don't know the strat.
You're not an avid reader.
You don't read.
You don't read these.
You don't need these strats if you don't know.
If you already read those, you already know.
You already know what the strat is.
Oh, you don't need to use Ao3.
It's for any fanfiction.
I don't read anymore.
In general.
Yeah, I don't.
I don't do that anymore.
I'm too busy gaming.
I'm just gaming now.
Wait, how did I get here?
What?
We're back to the haunted house?
This game is longer than I anticipated.
You see, back then.
On the PlayStation 2.
Um, you pay $50 for this.
$50 to $60.
And there's no Steam sale whatsoever.
And people act.
People com- You think like people back then complained a lot?
This- People.
About like, oh.
This game shouldn't be that expensive.
Blah, blah, blah.
Because it's like.
There's only that much playtime.
So like.
So like, yeah.
There was a lot.
People had padded games a lot more back then.
Especially when it's geared towards children.
Because children doesn't know what the fu- Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
I fucking- Oh my god.
There you are.
What?
Oh, there you are.
I see you.
One last face.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
I shall kick everything.
Okay, I need to get the winter.
And then the- The fall.
And then- Okay, there has to be.
There has to- Okay, there you go.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna find it here.
I don't think-
Guys.
I don't- Guys.
This is looking a little grim right now.
This is actually- This is- This is looking a little grim right now.
I don't think there's 50 cookies for me.
Okay, we need this and the trumpet guy.
Get over here.
Get over here!
Look at me!
Okay.
Alright.
I got spinny spin.
Okay, spinny spin got- This should be- Nice!
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah, that's- I knew it!
I was like, those- Those area has to be for something.
I knew it.
I knew that was for something.
Okay, and then we need trumpet.
Where would trumpet be though?
Is trumpet behind me?
I think trumpet was behind me.
Right?
That spinny spin is so strong.
I'm glad.
Do you exist?
I don't remember the map.
Wait, Trumpy Trump!
I'm gonna wake you up.
Get up!
Click!
Okay.
Oh.
Clank!
Get up!
Alright, that should be it.
And then we gotta get the winter.
Yay!
Summer!
Okay, and then we go this way.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
To be more wholesome.
Doki, I'm so excited for the concert.
If I see you in the fall 3D with other dragons!
I hope you're ready to see us also.
I know you- Yeah, me too!
I'm super excited!
I'm really excited.
I hope, like, my throat gets better though.
I'm, like, so behind on stuff because my throat is so, like, really fucked up.
Oh, no, no.
Not Trumpy Trump.
Trumpy Trump bad.
No!
The hole I go.
I hope maybe I can get a doctor's appointment, like, this week.
But that's wishful thinking.
Guys, that's me.
Thinking that, you know.
Thinking that, you know, there's actual doctors available.
I think I need to take a rest day and literally live in the hospital until, like, they take me in.
That's literally- That's literally all I can think of right now.
No, please let me take this.
Please!
Please, Woosa!
I don't think I can get into a walk-in clinic with an appointment.
You know what?
The reviews are a lie.
You know, I thought, like, it says, like, urgent and primary care.
But that's a fucking lie.
It's only urgent care.
I was reading the reviews and some of them were like, yeah, I just, like, went in in the morning and then I got to, I got to, you know, I got to see the, I got to see a doctor for my child.
And I'm just thinking, I'm like, is it because I'm not a child?
Am I not important?
Like...
Am I just not important because I'm not a child?
Literally, the child had the same symptoms as me.
I'm not sick enough.
I reset my fucking sick counter.
I should not have said, I should have withheld that information that I went to fucking America.
I should have withheld that information.
Oh, silly me for not withholding it.
Oh, silly me.
Silly me for trying to, thinking that I should tell the doctor everything that happened.
But no, just because, like, just because I was there two weeks ago.
It's not three weeks because it's a new virus, apparently.
I know.
I thought she would write me a prescription.
I thought that was what she was going to do.
If I tell her everything and she'll just write me a prescription.
Silly me.
It was just her telling me that I don't deserve to be at her doctor's place.
Okay, and then one last one.
Here you go, son.
Yeah, maybe Christopher Robin can cure me.
He just needs to tell me to stop being sick and then everything will be okay.
That's it, right?
It's just that easy, right?
Let's fucking go!
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, we did it.
We got- we're gonna find the stripes.
What the fuck?
What do you mean there's another- oh my god.
Okay, this is- okay.
What the fuck is wrong with you, Tigger?
Why a birthday candle?
You're not Eeyore!
Oh no, the PTSD is kicking in now.
Tigger, what the- no, sorry.
Tigger, what the fuck is going on?
Your demons are showing.
Oh hey, it looks better now.
No!
Now that I can see what's going on, it's not that bad.
To be fair, the fucking orange-green-orange does not really make it spooky.
It's the orange-green-orange color palette there.
One candle lit over one- you don't understand!
It's a- it's a better candle.
It's a grade S candle versus a grade A.
It's different candle brands, you don't understand.
Oh my god.
30 more to go- wait no, 40 more to go, 40 more to go.
Look, it's the size.
See?
The candle size is- what the fuck?
Holy shit.
What the fuck is that?
What the fu- oh my god, fucking bur- I'll burn the stripes right now.
No, don't do- no.
No.
If I don't catch- oh, this is act- no.
No, don't- don't do this to me.
No, that is fucked.
Don't- don't do this, don't do this.
Did it just disappear from my pocket?
I- I still have three more.
No, don't do this to me!
Come on.
No!
No, get back here and put out this fucking candle!
Come on.
No.
No, this is so fucked.
This is so fucked.
Please.
Please!
I can't.
Oh my god!
That's so mean.
That's actually so mean.
Please.
That is so fucking mean.
Why would they do this to me?
I'm just a little guy.
I'm- I'm just- I'm just a little guy.
Look how little I am.
Please tell me there's only two left.
Oh, thank god.
I swear to god.
Okay.
No way!
He just- he- Oh my god, he literally just 180s me.
Oh my- Oh, please.
Yes.
Okay.
Okay, we got the quarter.
You're next.
That's right, got you in the quarter.
Oh my god.
This is it.
I got his stripes.
Oh my god, and then the door's gonna come over.
I can feel it.
It's peak door hours now.
I feel the door calling to him.
Fucking laughing at me.
Telling me it's not over.
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, we're still- we're still in it.
Door hours just gonna come in and be like, JK, I'm gonna doink my stripes now.
I can feel it.
I can feel the door hours coming in.
Ayfin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Local Apex spread and Overwatch top 500 pilot can't be- No, you don't understand.
Their AI, it's- they're different.
You don't understand their AI.
It's not- it's not the same.
It's not like what you think it is.
20 years ago, their AI was different.
They didn't dumb it down for stupid children.
They're like, you're gonna learn today.
I mean, I never finished the game, so I clearly never learned.
No, it's true though.
I feel like games back then, they never- they didn't really dumb it down for people.
They're like, if you don't understand, then fucking, you're just stupid, I guess.
That's how the games were.
People literally just stopped playing it because they don't understand.
They left you alone.
They're like, fucking, if you can't do it, then fuck you, I guess.
What does Tigger want?
I think Tigger's trying to tell us he lost luck at a strife with Tigger.
Again?!
It sure doesn't sound like our Tigger.
I guess losing a strife has really made him scared.
Oh, it's the door.
We just have to find Tigger and his strife.
It's the door.
I don't guess I go fucking back!
I just got there!
I just- I just got here!
What are you- What do you mean?
I have to go back?!
I can feel it.
The door is like, you gotta get the last base, piglet.
If you wanna see a Tigger!
I can feel it.
I'm just gonna look at him.
Just get this- get the cutscene over with.
I'm just gonna get the cutscene over with.
I can feel him.
He's gonna be there and be like, you gotta get the last stripe!
The last base!
The dog needs his cookies.
Am I gonna see the door?
Am I gonna see his face?
It's loading pretty long!
Oh my god, am I gonna see your fucking ass face, door?
I fucking-
Alright, time to exit the dream!
He's back!
He's fucking back!
Oh my god!
Where can I find cookies?
Where?
I need 30.
I need 30 cookies left.
But where?
How did I miss 195?
Like, where?
Where?
Someone said press select and I can see it.
I don't know what it's gonna show up.
I pressed select so I'm gonna hide it real quick.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it does show it.
Oh my god, where?
Where?
How am I missing- Okay, there's that.
Okay.
Okay, here.
I am missing cookies here.
I'm here.
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna- Kick!
The one and twos add up.
Guys.
Guys, I think the one and two cookies added up.
Kick!
Oh, there's twos here.
They don't fuck around.
Okay, next door.
Next door.
They actually added up.
Who would've thought?
Who would've thought they added up?
It's back to kicking ours.
The goddamn door.
Stupid.
Fuck you.
I'm gonna kick him in the balls.
If I see that guy.
Oh my god, there you go.
It's that one cookie.
Of course it is.
Okay, we got this area.
Okay.
No, we're so close, guys.
We're so close.
We need- We need less than 20.
This is it.
The cookie hour is upon us.
And we'll never have to see him again.
And we'll kill him for good.
No, all of you, leave.
All of you, leave.
I have important kicking business to go to.
I don't care.
You don't matter.
Kick.
Where would it be?
Oh my god, no.
Get over here.
You're blocking my kicking.
The bookshelf?!
Are you- Guys, I figured out where it- Oh my god, it was the bookshelf.
This is where 100 of my cookies were.
Oh my god, I was literally missing 100 cookies from this area.
Oh my god, this is where I was missing 100 cookies.
It was the bookshelf.
It was the- Oh my god, okay.
I'm done.
I'm done with this dream.
It's okay, I just need 140.
I just need 140.
Alright.
I need 100.
I needed 150.
My god.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming back, everybody.
Knock, knock.
I'm the one who knocks.
I've never watched this show.
I say a reference I never really understood.
My Oshie is so smart and literate.
Not so deadfoot.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Run.
I'm here for the cookies.
That's right.
One at a time.
Okay, this should give me a lot.
Alright, nice.
This should give me the last two.
And then I got an extra one just for like a road trip.
Just to treat myself, you know?
Just because of a good job I did.
I'm gonna get myself one just to treat myself.
Jayden, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
My birthday is later this week and I'm 100% making cookies now.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I close my eyes and all I see...
All I see are cookies.
I close my eyes and that's all I see.
In this forest, all I see is cookies.
Here I go.
This is it.
The last phase.
The final countdown.
I'm fucking booking it.
I'm running.
That's right.
I'm fucking getting over.
I'm gonna murder this door.
I'm gonna make sure to...
I'm gonna murder him and I'm gonna cut him up into pieces.
Put him into a sawdust...
A sawdust shredder.
Then like...
Then burn it again.
And then, I don't know, feed it to beavers.
I'm fucking...
Feed it to termites.
If I separate all pieces of him into dust...
Into termites...
Then like...
Then he'll never be able to come back.
Yes, a wood chip.
Because I'm terminally online.
You think I don't know what a fucking wood...
Know the name of an actual wood chipper thing is?
The fact that I got this far is already impressive enough.
No.
Don't let me buy my face.
Let me buy my face.
Okay.
Alright, what is the final phase?
What is this?
What the fuck?
The fuck are you doing?
Okay, to be fair, I think the second last phase is scarier.
The second last phase is...
I think the second last phase is the scariest one out of all of them.
That one...
Like, the second last phase is fucking canny as shit.
Yeah, the spin is so much worse.
This is just like...
Ah!
We should bottom up you up.
His face expands to eat the door.
Alright.
Alright, this is the final countdown.
Tigger, I got you.
Huh?
What the fuck?
What happened to him?
Does he show up in the game like that too?
Oh no, it was just a cutscene.
What did you do, Piglet?
What?
Oh, he changes it.
Okay, that's annoying.
How many does it take?
What?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I got it.
It's three.
It has to be three.
There's three of them too!
Oh my god, get these weasels out of here.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine, because I need the double...
Okay, I need a number.
Okay, and then I leave.
I run.
I run!
Get out, get out, get out!
I have to give more distance.
Run!
Nice, okay.
The double square really helps.
That's right, you ended up helping me!
You idiot!
That was helpful!
Look at me.
Look at me!
That's what you write, look at me!
Okay, that's enough space then.
I should be able to get that.
Okay, that is plenty of space.
Oh, he changes the arrows too!
Oh, fuck.
Oh, nice.
The double triangle.
Okay, that's convenient.
Thank you, you actually made this easier for me, you fucking idiot!
Oh, okay, I need to grab the last one.
I almost forgot to grab the last potion.
Tigger!
Oh my god.
I'd rather just burn these.
I get so fucking uncanny!
Oh, Tigger, where have you been?
I got all surrounded by Woozles, see?
So, I bounced in here to think of a plan for getting past them.
Oh my god, you did it!
This place is Woozle-free!
You know, pale and all, pal, I think that you might be just almost as brave as a Tigger!
Almost?
You really think so?
Oh my god, almost perfect just like him!
And so it was, that thanks to his dream...
We did it!
Even if his friend Piglet did not look like a Tigger, he certainly had the courage and strength of one.
Oh my god, we fucking did it!
I'm back to being my same old self, with all my Tiggerific strengths!
And a safe to you, Piglet!
We made everybody... we made them all love us!
And they're all gonna wake up and be like...
Oh my god, it's crazy!
We had dreams about you!
Oh, that's so sad, Eeyore!
But it's okay, he's happy now!
Oh,
they're gonna drown!
Piglet, if you don't do anything, they'll all fucking drown!
Jesus Christ!
Wait, what?
It's not over?
Wait, wait!
Silly Doki!
Of course it's not over!
You have one more level to go!
Wait...
What?
You wanna be a real hero?
Wait, what's gonna happen?
Wait, but I'm not... I'm not a dream!
I can die in reality!
Wait, they're real?
You mean to tell me they weren't part of my dreams?
They're real?
Oh shit!
Wait...
What am I supposed to do with these?
Wait, I got your memory!
Owl, look!
Do you remember?
What?
Just fly!
What the fuck?!
Without me?!
You're a fucking freak!
Stupid owl!
Just fly!
Oh, guess he's gone!
Bye!
Hey owl, you wanna help our friends out?
And you know, I don't fucking know...
Owl, don't you wanna help our friends out right now?
Crow forgot to fly!
And then he flew away!
I saved him!
Okay, the worst part is that he just fucking flew away right after.
Our friends are gonna die!
He's just like, well...
Me, thank you for the super chat!
Run, run, run, run, run, run!
You mean it didn't take too long?
Oh my god, run, run, run!
I'm sorry Pooh Bear, don't look!
Don't look, close your eyes!
Okay...
That's what I'm saying!
He's supposed to be the smartest one!
Oh my god, it takes three?
Me, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
How many game-breaking bugs did I miss?
There wasn't a lot, I think our biggest one was the beginning.
I did it, Pooh!
Oh, he just walks over!
He could've done that!
With the health lumps chasing after him!
Walking him by!
Wait, that's so shallow!
Wait, I just realized how shallow the water was!
Wait a minute!
Like it was...
Do I even need a bridge at that point?
Bite me!
Bite me, you fucker!
That's fucking right!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I hate that it takes three!
So I have to like...
Oh my God, no!
No, where's Christopher Robin when I need him?
Where is he when I need him to tell me to stop being sad?
Okay.
No, no, are you serious?
No!
Put the lump extra off right now.
Oh no.
Oh no, if I can die in real life!
Okay.
Okay, I can do it.
I can do it, I can get like coverage.
Alright, now this is fine.
This is so fast!
He's so fast too!
Oh, no, no, no!
I just made it!
Oh my God, 1 HP.
Alright, Rue.
I swear to God, if you jump over, I swear to fucking God.
Oh wait, we have a bridge.
We have a bridge, thank God.
Okay.
We have a bridge, he can't just jump over at least.
Okay, okay.
That's my loading screen.
It's like they're gonna get me.
You alright?
Oh shit, I forgot about my other friends.
Oh my God.
I hate him.
I hate him so much.
Okay, okay.
Piglet, please.
He's just there.
Piglet, who would you choose?
Who would you possibly choose?
No, no, not Gambler, man.
No!
Not Gambler, man!
Anyway, what do I do?
It'll be fine.
Who cares?
It'll be okay.
It'll be fine.
Let's just deal with him first.
Oh no, not Gambler, man.
Okay, nice.
I think what I don't like is the fact that it takes three tries now.
Okay.
I don't trust myself for this, so I'm just gonna make sure...
What the fuck?
He just starts running!
Tigger, just give me a sec.
Just give me a sec.
I got one more try.
I literally have one HP.
I forgot I had, like, other friends.
I thought it was over when I saved three people.
Upside down!
Thank you for the one-gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, Tigger, you're free now.
Oh, thank you, big little pal!
You're just a lifesaver, a hero!
You got me out of that flood, and buddy...
I think it's time to lose, like, a friend or two, and we know which friend it is.
Yay!
We did it!
We saved him!
Okay, and then we gotta get the carrot here.
I think, like, if I put the carrot in here...
Then it's gonna...
It's gonna cause it to fall, right?
Yeah.
Hey, we lost our entire harvest, but that's okay.
Where's the gamba?
Gamba man?
Gamba man, I see you.
Oh no, it's Gamba Man.
Oh my god, I hate Gamba Man the most.
I hate him, I hate him so much.
Oh my god, really?
Really?!
I hate you!
Oh, there's no way.
The thing is, I can't.
I need to run.
This is your fault, rabbit!
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
How did I leave it?!
I can't risk it, I'm literally 1 HP.
I...
I think the worst part is that I picked the wrong ones.
The worst part is that I keep picking the wrong ones too.
It's not like... no.
Are you serious?!
I didn't...
I just died!
That's a thing?!
Oh, he's dead.
Well, I guess he's...
I...
I'm totally kidding!
No way!
I pick up... I hate him!
I hate him!
I hate him so much!
Oh my god, I hate him!
I hate him!
Oh my god!
Stupid rabbit!
Naturally stupid fucking rabbit!
Rabbit claims another victim.
We were so close!
How was I supposed to know he didn't fucking...
He dies!
He just dies!
Like...
Oh my god.
I can't believe he just dies.
It's just like, whoop, he's dead now.
Okay.
Alright, then we grab this.
Alright, we skip all of this.
Kick it, Piglet!
Please, we're so close!
It's cause of the bee!
The bee was so difficult!
He's so fast!
Oh my god, if I exit that dream, I swear to god, I was gonna fucking...
Oh my god, if I accidentally exit that dream...
Okay, I'm not taking chances.
I'm not...
Guys, I'm not taking chances.
Guys, I've gone through so much.
Okay, that should be enough.
No, no, no, no, no!
I
hate him!
I hate him!
I hate this!
Oh my god, I hate him!
I hate him so much!
Oh my god, he's dead.
He's fucking dead.
Stupid bee.
At least Owl, I don't have to fight him, actually.
This sucks, cause I'm on the... I'm at the second stage.
In the second stage, I'm just like, slower.
Just fly.
Just fucking fly.
It's that easy.
Okay, I'm just a little afraid.
Okay, it's figure time.
Nice, and then...
Oh my god, please Piglet, please!
I just need you to grab the brush!
Okay.
This is gonna be difficult, cause Mirror Man is the one after.
I... I hate... I hate Rabbit.
I feel like Rabbit's gonna be the death of me again.
Oh.
I think Rabbit's gonna kill me again.
I... I just have this feeling that...
I don't know.
Just this feeling that Rabbit's gonna fuck me over yet again.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god he goes really slow.
The Gamma Man.
He's gonna come over.
Gamma Man.
I can feel the Gamma Man.
Okay.
Gamma Man time!
Gamma time!
It's Gamma time!
Oh my god, please don't fucking stutter here.
Alright.
Hey Gamma.
Can't believe we're not supposed to lead him.
This is like... it's so dumb.
Get over here.
Okay, I don't have a lot here.
I gotta make sure he doesn't go to Rabbit.
I gotta...
Really?
Okay.
Alright.
Run.
Run, stupid Gamma.
Stupid Gamma.
I fucking hate you.
I hate you so much.
I hate you.
I hate you!
I hate you so much.
The worst part is, it's like...
It's like, I have to do so much for this face!
No, run!
I just gotta be lucky!
Stop laughing!
Okay.
Okay, Elephant Man.
Elephant Man.
Elephant Man, please.
Don't get near Rabbit.
Please, I can't do this again.
Okay.
I can do two, I think.
I can fit two in.
I think I can fit two in.
Yeah, I can fit two in.
If I'm green... I think I can fit three in.
I think I can do it.
Yes!
Three!
Okay, it's just Gamma.
It was just a Gamma.
Three.
Okay, Rabbit, you're free now.
You're welcome.
Ugh.
Oh my god, you still care about the carrots?
Piglet, don't.
Piglet, don't smile.
He's taking advantage of you.
He's taking advantage of you, Piglet.
Don't let your... Don't be a fucking fool.
Alright, Eeyore, I'm coming over, Eeyore.
If I die to Eeyore, of all things, I'm...
If I die to Eeyore, I'm just... I don't know what I'm gonna do.
I'm just a mirror guy.
He's really scary, too.
Hello?
Oh no.
Nice, okay.
How far is he?
Okay, we're gonna... Yeah, I'm not gonna risk that.
That's weird.
It seems way too close.
Oh no.
Oh no, I can't.
Okay, got that.
Can I fit?
No, I don't trust myself.
I don't think I can fit.
No!
Why are you walking?
No, Piglet!
Piglet, why you walk?
Piglet!
No way!
He had to walk.
Wait, what?
No, I can't see.
I can't register it.
I'm so... I can't register it!
I'm panicking!
I hate this!
No.
Oh, we did it!
That has to be three, right?
Okay.
Yes!
I can't!
I can't read upside down!
It's okay, Eeyore.
I already had to deal with Rabbid.
It's okay.
Oh my god, did we do it?
I don't have any friends left, right?
Did we do it?
There's no more friends left, right?
Yeah!
Oh, what?
What's going on?
There is a boss?
No.
There's no way.
If I... There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way.
The worst part is I have to do this in three tries.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, there's... I have to do this in three tries!
Oh my god, they're doing... Oh my god, this is... That's so much pressure!
Are you serious?
Oh!
Oh, to do that!
How are children supposed to do that?
Oh my god.
Children were... Children never made it to the end.
Oh, Chrissy comes after.
Where have I been?
Did nothing happen, Christopher Robin?
Thanks for nothing, Chris.
No.
All credit goes to Christopher Robin, of course.
Please, not cookies.
Did we just get a head pat?
That's it?
Did no one... Did they not acknowledge that I nearly saved 100 acres woods?
Oh my god, but we did it.
Oh my god.
We did it, guys.
We haven't had a one-off beating a game in one sitting in a long... Oh hey, Jim Cummings and Peter Collins.
See, there they are.
We haven't had a one-off beating a game in one go in a long time.
Oh my... There's no way a child would have fucking beat the last boss.
There's no way.
Like, I was tapping it as fast as I could, and I was already, like, this close to getting killed.
Like, there's no way.
I refuse to believe... Oh hey, that's me.
I refuse to believe a child got past the last boss.
Oh my god.
There's no way.
Well, that was fun.
I'm glad to share you guys my childhood game that I never beat.
But I beat it now, guys.
The difference is that now I have adult reflexes.
And, like, I'm not... I play Silent Hill now, so I'm not scared of this game.
Recycling!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
You were all here, chat.
You were all here.
I'm most likely going to take tomorrow off because, like, my voice is dead.
But I will stream on Thursday and Friday and Saturday.
But I'll take Wednesday off.
I'm sorry for taking a lot of days off.
I'm trying to rest my voice a lot more because of my coughing and stuff and my, you know, trying to find a fucking doctor.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Will there be more games in your PS2 in the future?
Maybe.
Realized, wow, I can play PS2 games now.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rage, thank you for the superchat.
I think you made it harder when switching to that last- YOU HAD TO HAVE THE LAST FACE!
YOU CAN'T SWAP FACES!
THAT'S THE WORST PART!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Golden, thank you for the superchat.
I wanted to say I'm back and you're still here.
Go home, movie is over.
Yep, we finally did it.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jay, please- I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best.
There's no doctors that want to see me.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Derp, thank you for the superchat.
I told you one last job.
I knew it.
The one last job.
It was the last.
You'll never know where I live now.
Don Cookie Monster will never know where I go now.
Thank you for the superchat.
Derp, thank you, thank you.
Thank you everybody for watching!
I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flow.
Oh my gosh, we just see Piglet's rump.
Get that blood flowing.
You stay up for me?
Head to bed, guys.
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!